hello everyone and welcome to this
google analytics full course video by
simply learn
today we will understand google
analytics which is the best
analytical tool provided by google to
check up on our website
we will understand how google analytics
works
how we can use it to measure the
performance of our website
we'll also understand how to set up
goals and create events that will help
us keep our website on track
next we will look at google tag manager
and towards the end
we will unlock the mystery of how to
rank at number one position
on google it's not that hard as you
think it
is we have rob with us who has more than
15 years of experience in digital
marketing
and analytics and he will take us
through these topics
over to you rob welcome everyone this is
rob
sanders with simply learn and today
we're going to talk about google
analytics
i'm very excited to be with you today
because google analytics
is one of my favorite google platforms
and my favorite topics
so let's talk about what we're going to
cover today and we're going to start out
with
how to set up a google analytics account
and so
we're going to talk about everything
that entails including creating your
google analytics account
we're going to talk about setting up a
property in your account
and what a property is we're going to
talk about setting up a reporting view
in your property
and we're going to talk about installing
the tracking code so those are the
series of steps
we're going to go through today in terms
of
setting up a google analytics account so
let's get right
to it and so really the prerequisite
here
when it comes to setting up a google
analytics account
is to have a google login and id
so when you actually go to google
analytics
you need to be able to sign up or sign
in
and so once you actually sign in then
you're gonna go
walk through a series of steps but
really that's really all you need
to get the account going is a google id
and login
so if you have a gmail account or an
other
email account that you use for other
google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually
go to sign up for google analytics
you're going to be
asked to set up a new account and these
are the series of steps you're going to
walk through or go
through to set up a new google analytics
account
so you're going to choose an account
name and then you're going to choose a
property name okay so the account name
can be anything you want it to be
the name your company your name whatever
you want to name it
the property name is really the website
name
so what website are we talking about so
here i'm going to set up a fictitious
website name
for now it's called demo simply learn so
the url for this website demo simply
learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
and analytics we're really
talking about what websites we want to
measure
and then you're going gonna be asked to
choose an industry category
and so for simply learn we're in jobs
and education but you have a
number of different industries that you
could choose from this is important go
ahead and choose the
most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and i'm gonna talk about why that's
important here in a minute
and then you're gonna choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because
that's when the day starts in analytics
and the day
ends based on that time zone so the data
that google analytics collects
starts and ends with that time zone so
very important
to choose the time zone your business is
located in okay and then you have some
additional options here okay so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow google products and services
so
if you opt into this then basically
what google's gonna do is share some
products and services with you
via email i would go ahead and opt into
that that's of course recommended by
google
it doesn't hurt to hear from google on
related products and services that
may enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so
benchmarking to me is something you
should opt into
so going back to that industry and
category we chose jobs and education
so by opting into benchmarking basically
what google's going to do
is share your data that it collects on
your website
in this case demo.simplylearn.com it's
going to
share that data anonymously
with others in the industry in this case
jobs and education
and because you've opted in it's going
to
do the same exact thing for you it's
going to share
anonymous data on other websites in
the same industry and the benefit of
that is
we get to see what other websites or how
other websites are performing compared
to ours what's the benchmark
in our industry and so the benchmarking
to me
is important and i'm gonna go over that
in a few minutes when we go over the
different reports but
to me i would always opt into
benchmarking because
this is the only report google provides
in analytics about
how others in your industry is
performing versus
your website okay so it's a way to
compare your website performance
against others in the same industry the
other options here
technical support and account specialist
i would also recommend you opt-in to
those
because then it allows you to basically
uh google allow google access to your
account and they'll be able to help you
if you occur or run into any issues so
these are the options in setting up
a google analytics account it's very
simple very
easy to do you're just entering in a few
fields
note that we talking about a website
right now so i'm talking about
demo.simplylearn.com
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app
google analytics will allow you to do
that as well you just choose the option
mobile app so we're tracking a website
we want to know how users behave when
they get to my website and that's what
google analytics is going to allow us to
measure
and look at we just need to do a couple
more steps in the process so
once we fill out these fields here we're
going to click get tracking id
now i'm going to accept the terms of
service
i'm going to accept another terms and
service
in relation to data protection i'm gonna
click accept
once i accept i'm gonna be able to get
some
tracking code the tracking id is the id
associated with your account and so
this number is going to be associated
with your account so your account id
starts with ua and it's going to be this
number here
now the dash one is the property you set
up
so in this case i set up
demo.simplylearn.com
if i wanted to track multiple websites
under that same account then i can
certainly set up multiple properties
just know that every property i set up
in that account
is going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
etc depending on how many properties i
set up
so by default i set up one property so
my
first property id is dash one if i set
up a second
property the same account number it's
just gonna have a dash two and that's
important because
that id that account and property id
is going to be associated with that
particular property or website
so again once you finish setting up the
account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account
and the property so notice my tracking
id up here
notice the tracking id and the snippet
of code now
this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website
that you want to track and you don't
have to put it on every page
but if you want to track website
behavior on every page your website
then it needs to go on every page of
your website so if you're using
a you know platform like drupal or
joomla or even more popular platform
like wordpress
adding the tracking code site-wide is as
easy as
maybe adding a google analytics plug-in
to wordpress for example
and then just simply plugging in the id
now there's an alternative to adding
the google analytics tracking code to
your site
and that's google tag manager so google
tag manager
is the way i would recommend going so if
you're not familiar with google tag
manager i would recommend
watching the youtube video we have on
google tag manager
you can just go to youtube type in
simply learn google tag manager
and this will give you a nice overview
of
you know what google tag manager is and
how it works but basically
this is the way i would go and i would
recommend that
in addition having google analytics you
set up a google tag manager account
and then that way you can put the
tracking code
in google tag manager so if i go to
google tag manager
and i just go into an account on tag
manager
i can just simply put in the
google analytics id right into
tag manager and so if i have it in tag
manager
then tag manager is going to be the
place that
holds the code and fires page view when
somebody comes to my website so that way
i don't have to add
the tracking code to my website if i do
it in
tag manager so that's the recommended
method for me
is to add the google analytics id
associated with tag manager
if you can associate it with tag manager
then that's the easier route to go
versus putting code on your website okay
so again
take a look at the video we have on
youtube for google tag manager
that's the route i would go now once you
do
get the tracking code on your website
whether that be
through google tag manager or through a
plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site
then what's gonna happen is you're gonna
start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code
to your website now if you're not ready
to do that and you simply
want to basically understand how google
analytics works
then i would recommend getting access to
google analytics demo account and so
if you just type in and search google
analytics demo account
basically what you're going to do you're
going to choose the first
listing there and you're going to go to
demo account so
if you have a google analytics or google
login
then all you need to do is click on
access demo account and so what google's
going to do
is put this demo account into your
account
and so it's going to look something like
this so if i click on demo account here
it's going to add to my google analytics
account
so i'm going to have then access to
the demo account from google and google
analytics
so i would recommend going this route
here if you're not
familiar you're not sure what you're
getting yourself into
so think of the demo account as kind of
a test drive you're test driving google
analytics before you even add
any code to your website so again all
you need is a google account and if you
have a google account
and you add the demo account to your
google analytics account you're going to
be able to see
how analytics works okay and so that's
what i would also recommend so if you're
not ready to start adding
code to your website then what you can
do
is just simply add the demo account and
then once you add the demo account
you're free to peruse around google
analytics
to see the different types of reports it
has to offer now when you
do actually set up a google analytics
account
you're going to have some settings that
you're going to want to pay attention to
so when you set up the account you have
the account name
and then you have a property so under
each property you have by default you're
going to have one view
and so here you can see this view here
so if we look at the account we set up
we set up a demo simply learn account
property is demo
simply learn so that's associated with
the website we're going to track
and then again by default under each
property
you're going to have a view and so by
default
the name of the view is going to be
called all website data
and so in that view is where all your
analytics
data is going to be stored so you can
see my screen here there's a lot of
different
settings you have you have settings
under
the account you have settings under the
property and you have settings
under the view so we're going to talk
more about these settings in future
webinars
for advanced google analytics users but
for now
know that there's a bunch of settings
that you have that you can play around
with
when it comes to google analytics
anything from adding users
to your google analytics account your
google analytics property or view
you can actually set up goals you can
set up filters
you can set up segments you can link up
google ads
you can you know set up remarketing list
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to google
analytics
but so no those settings are there
they're located
right down here and this little sprocket
icon that's the admin icon
so if you need to get to these settings
at any time you can simply just click on
the sprocket or the admin icon and then
you'll be
prompted to choose any one of these
settings here that you want to
edit or alter so now let's take a look
at some google analytics reports
so once you've actually set up your
account you have
a number of different reports that you
have available to you in google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at
you know customize reports we're going
to look at real time
audience reports acquisition behavior
and conversion so these are all the
different reporting
buckets if you will that you have
available to you
in google analytics so if i'm an admin
and i'm looking at the google demo
account let's start out by looking at
real time
so if i click on the real time report
and i just click on overview so
basically what this is going to do
is show me at this point in time
how many users i actually have active on
the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior
of users who are currently on your
website and so
this is the overview report under real
time
and you can see here i can see that 79
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent coming from
tablet here i can see
how they actually came to the website so
this is the referring
source if they came from say search or
social i can see the source there
and i can see what pages they're active
on and then here i can see what
locations
where they're located and so if i want
to see a breakdown of everything in the
overview i can certainly do that if i go
to locations under real time
i could see a majority of my users are
coming from the united states
okay where are they coming from i'll
just click on
traffic sources and here i could see the
different
sources and mediums medium is the means
in which the traffic was driven
so if it's google it's either paid
search or organic search so i can see
here it's organic
then i can actually see what content
they're looking at
on my website so i could see currently
have
three active users on the home page two
active users
on the google's women's white tee page
so forth and so on now most importantly
if you have event tracking set up so if
you
taking a look at our google tag manager
webinar
you know that you could set up event
tracking in google analytics to
measure engagement on your website
whether that be a form submission
or somebody clicking on the play button
of a video
so if i click on events i'll be able to
see
what events are firing so here i can see
we have event tracking set up and i can
see
how many different events are firing on
my website
in real time so here i can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view
click some a couple of users clicking on
add to cart
a couple of users clicking on the
promotion click and as these events are
fired you're gonna be able to see
them highlighted so if something gets
fired it's going to get highlighted
and i could see that these are the
current events
that i have currently firing on the
website and
that's what's currently fire now if i
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes i can
just click on this link here
last 30 minutes and it's going to give
me an overview
of the events that have happened over
the past 30 minutes
okay so that's event tracking and then
more importantly
we can also look at what conversions are
happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now i can see
i had one active user who entered the
checkout so that's goal number four
so in analytics you can have up to 20
goals and so here i can see
we have goal number four has already had
one active user
and so if i look at the last 30 minutes
i can see i still have only one goal
over the last 30 minutes and that was
somebody who entered the checkout so
that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently
happening on your website and so for me
ideally
if i'm launching a campaign or let's
just say you do a new
website redesign and you want to see how
users performing and behaving
then real time is a good option for you
so you can see how things are happening
in real time now let's jump down to
audience reporting so if i click on
audiences
it's just right underneath real time i'm
going to see
a number of different reports available
to me
under audience and so let's click on the
audience overview report so audience
reporting
basically allows us to get a sense of
who is coming to our website when i say
who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
specific person in fact google doesn't
allow
personally identifiable information
in google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name
a social security number credit card
information
etc however we can still paint
a nice picture on who is coming to our
website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from
what language what device do they get to
our website from
how old were they okay were they male or
female or other
what interest did they have what browser
did they use
so we can paint a nice picture based on
all this information
that google analytics is providing us
under audience
so if i go to audience overview here i
can see i have all these different
options available to me to get a basic
understanding
of who is coming to our website so for
example
i could see a majority of the people
coming to our website
speak english and are from the united
states okay in fact that represents
61 of the users and so google analytics
does a great job
of giving me an overall percentage so
if i have a 100 of the users i could see
61
of those users represented
english-speaking users from the united
states
seven percent represented
english-speaking users
from great britain and so when it comes
to analytics we have users
and users are broken down into two
categories
they're either returning or they're new
so
when you add the google analytics
tracking script to your website what's
going to happen is
if a user or when a user goes to your
website they're going to get cookied
if it's the first time they've been to
your website what google analytics is
going to do is store a cookie in the
browser so
when that same user comes back another
day
in the same browser analytics is going
to recognize that that cookie
is in the browser and so then analytics
is going to categorize that
user as a returning user okay so that's
how analytics is able to differentiate
new versus returning so if that user
doesn't have a cookie in the browser
then analytics is going to recognize
that store the cookie
and then count that user as a new user
and so when you're looking in analytics
you're going to be able to see a
breakdown
of new versus returning so here i can
see
over three quarters of my traffic
over the past week here i can see april
6 through april 12
three over three quarters are new users
to the website here i could see about 23
24
our returning users okay so i can get a
good
breakdown of what type of users are
coming
am i driving new traffic am i driving
traffic that's been to my website before
what language are they speaking okay i
can also paint a bigger picture
how old are they are they what gender
are they do they come from mobile so
let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience
so if i skip down now to demographics
i can click on overview and when that
report loads
i can see now under demographics
overview
i can see the breakout of
age ranges and so here i can see the
majority of the traffic
coming to my site again over the past
week now if i want to change this date
range i could simply do that
i can change the date range just by
clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and i can even compare it to the
previous
period or the previous year i'm going to
choose the last 30 days
i'm going to click apply now i'm looking
at data over the last
30 days and again you can change the
date range to any
range you want you can only go back as
far as when you
actually created the google analytics
account you can't go
prior to that so here i'm looking at the
last 30 days
and i can see almost 47
of my users were in their age range of
25 to 34.
now when it comes to gender i can see
66 represent males
so i can get a breakout of gender
and age as well as interest i can click
on interest
and look at the overview there and see
what the interest is of the users who
are coming to my site
based on in-market segments or affinity
i can also choose
language and location so if i want to
know exactly
where my users are located when they're
coming to my website i can click on
location
and here i can get a breakout 43 percent
of the users of the last 30 days were
from the united states
more importantly i can align my audience
with goals and we'll talk about goals
here in a minute but here i can see
if i have an e-commerce website i can
see of those 43 percent
0.29 of those converted or
purchased something and that equates to
94 transactions
so i can get a good sense of not only
how many users are coming from
a specific country but are those users
converting
if i click on mobile and mobile to me is
one of those reports
i tend to spend a bit of time on because
i want to know
what devices users are coming to my
website and so
for my website here or this is the
google demo website
i can see mobile represents
approximately 27
of the traffic so desktop still
represents a majority of the traffic
so for you you want to keep an eye on
mobile because mobile
is definitely a majority of what people
use nowadays
that's how people start their day that's
how they transact
via mobile whether that's purchasing
something communicating
or searching it all starts with mobile
so you want to keep an eye on mobile
and more importantly you want to keep an
eye on behavior
so google analytics is telling me that
yes i
have approximately 27 of my traffic of
the last 30 days came from mobile
how are they interacting with my website
so
if i look across this report
i'm going to be able to see different
metrics so if i'm measuring
specific metrics against my
dimension in this case the dimension is
what we're measuring
and in this example we're measuring
mobile i can see
that the bounce rate is approximately 48
and bounce rate means that if a user in
this case from mobile
landed on a page they left the site
without going
any further so they consider it a bounce
if they don't go
to another page if they leave the site
from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people
who come to the site and leave the site
without going any further
so in this case we have 48 bounce rate
that's almost half of our users who come
from mobile
leave the website from the page they
landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's
open to interpretation is definitely
subjective
but you want to keep the bounce rate as
low as possible you want to keep people
on your site especially if you have an
e-commerce website you want
people who come to your website to
purchase
and so here we can see 48 percent mobile
in desktop it's a little bit lower at 41
now if i look a little bit further at
engagement i can see
how many pages on average do mobile
users look at
so versus desktop it's a little bit
lower you can see
3.86 on desktop it's 4.5
now if i look a little bit further in
engagement
i want to be able to measure how long
somebody from mobile
stays on the website if they're bouncing
at 48
but they're also looking at 3.8 pages
3.9 almost four pages per session
then that means in this report analytics
is telling me they're spending about
two minutes on the site and
interestingly enough i can see that
mobile over the last 30 days had
more transactions so 51 transactions
versus 34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough
the commerce conversion rate is at .29
percent
that's higher than desktop at 0.07
it's lower than tablet but it's higher
than desktop
and mobile has the most transactions and
since they have the most transactions
they have the most revenue at 2 380. so
yes the engagement isn't exactly as
great as it is as desktop
but we can see that people are still
purchasing with their mobile devices
so it's something to keep an eye on and
mobile is something i definitely look
at in fact since it's such an important
report
one thing you can do in analytics is if
you actually like a report and you think
you're going to look at that report
multiple times then you can simply just
go ahead and click
save at the top here so if i click save
i'm going to enter a name for this
report i'm just going to call it mobile
report and click ok and then what's
going to happen is
it's going to be located under save
reports and save reports
is located under customization
customization is located above real time
okay so if i close that up you can see
audience real time customization if i
click on customization
if i click on save reports i should be
able to see
my save report here and i do so here i
can see
mobile report if i click on it i can
simply go to the report i was looking at
before i saved it so save reports to me
is a good feature in analytics because
it
allows you to quickly access a report
that you've saved in the past so let's
take a look at one more
report under audience and let's go to
benchmarking
so remember when we were setting up our
analytics account
we had the option to opt into
benchmarking
and i recommended you do so and so if
you did
actually opt into benchmarking then
you're going to be able to see
how your site compares to others in the
same industry
so if i click on benchmarking and then
click on channels
what i'm actually able to do now is
compare
my website with others in the same
industry
so if i go back to say jobs and
education
and i choose education all education
as my industry vertical i should be able
to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how i compare with those
websites
so i'm choosing all countries i can
narrow that down if i wanted to
i can just search for the united states
i can choose a specific state
and then i can choose a particular site
size
so here i'm choosing sites by daily
session so these are sites that have
an average of 5 000 to almost 10
000 sessions a day and so in this
vertical education
in the united states sites that have 5
000
to 99999 sessions per day
that means that there are approximately
310
web properties contributing to this
report okay based on this criteria
i chose now if my site is similar
meaning if i'm in the united states if
i'm in education
and i'm receiving 5 000 to 99999
sessions per day
then i'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now google's
sharing this data anonymously
from the other websites and they're
doing the same with your website
to those particular websites
benchmarking reports okay
so it's a shared data anonymously in
particular
industries and verticals and so now i'm
looking at a channel report so if i want
to see how i compare to others
in my industry then i can go ahead
and see by channel for example am i
driving as much
traffic as others in my industry and you
can see i'm not
in fact i'm 76 77 percent
worse in terms of the amount of traffic
being driven from organic search
so anything in red is going to show as a
negative result
a negative comparison whereas something
in green
is a positive comparison so if i look at
engagement
i can see that i might not be driving as
much traffic
but i can see that the pages per session
are better than the site average or the
industry average
i can see if i go over again looking
just at organic search i can see the
bounce rate is better than the industry
average
so the channel report under benchmarking
allows you
to measure how you compare to others in
your industry
and you could do so by looking at
location and devices
so if you opted into benchmarking when
you set up your account
then you'll be able to compare your
website against
others in your industry in your country
region
and based on the size of your website in
terms of
how many visitors or sessions you're
getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition
so if audience is who is coming to your
website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic
was driven to your website so how do
these users
get to our website and so under
acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning or new
came to our website and so what
analytics does by default
is they have a number of default
channels and when we say channels
we mean analytics is grouping different
channels based on how users got to your
website meaning
how did users get to our website did
they come via organic search
meaning did they type something into
google and find you
in the organic listing analytics also
groups users based on
whether they came to your site directly
meaning did they
type in the url directly into the
browser
or did they bookmark your website and
come back via the bookmark
so they're grouping users under direct
they also group users under referral
meaning do they come from another
website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform
like twitter or facebook if you're
running paid
search meaning if you're running paid
search on say google
then do they come from paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
google's network
google's display network that's a
default channel so
analytics will group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default google analytics groups users
on how they came to your website
via these default channels and so i can
see
how many users came to the site from
each channel
now if i want to drill down on this
report i can click on
all traffic and then if i click on all
traffic i can go to channels
i can look specifically at the channels
report and so
now i can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic
and they represent approximately again
you can see this number here in
parentheses
next to the raw number of users i can
see that number's about 56
so 56 of my traffic over the last 30
days
came from organic search and so those
are the number
users again as a metric you're also
going to have sessions
and you'll see sessions a lot as a
metric so
users are broken down between new and
returning
so every time a new or returning user
comes to the website
basically what they're doing is
initiating a session
so you can have a user who can come back
multiple times every time they come back
to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of
somebody coming to your website and the
session ends when they leave the website
and so just like we looked at with
the audience reports when it came to
mobile
we can also look at engagement by
channel
so just like mobile we looked at bounce
rate pages per session
average session duration we can do the
same thing
here with our channel report more
importantly
in addition to behavior we can see
conversions
and since we're running an e-commerce
platform we could see what the
conversion rate is by channel
so organic search did drive the most
traffic
and they did have the most transactions
over the last 30 days
and the conversion rate in this case is
0.17 okay so
how google determines the conversion
rate they basically take
the number of transactions and divide
that by sessions
so that means that over the last 30 days
organic search drove 38 123 sessions
and of those 38 123 64 actually
turned into a transaction which equates
to 0.17
which also equates to 3 000 in revenue
so
i'm able to determine not only how users
are getting to my website
by looking at the channel report i can
actually see
if they're engaging and if they are
converting
and notice when you look at a report in
analytics
you can look at it by channel you'll
also get a summary
so here i can see a summary or a total
based on my date range so i could see
over the last 30 days
i've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that
meant that at those 54 000 users i had
70
000 sessions i could see my average
bounce rate was 43 percent
the pages per session were just over
four and the average session duration
how long did somebody stay on my website
on
average about two minutes and 55 seconds
the average conversion rate was 0.14 and
i had a total of 97
transactions totaling 5500
okay and that's all over the last 30
days so any report you look at in
analytics
is gonna have a summary and note that
any report you look at in analytics
is going to allow you to save it so if
it's a report you
think you're going to go back and look
at at a future date
then you simply just have to click on
the save button
conversely if you don't want to save it
you can simply just
export it so you can export it as a pdf
if i click on pdf
it's going to allow me to export that as
a pdf
now you have other options available to
you as well you can do
a google sheet you can export it as an
excel
or you can export it as a comma
delimited file
so here you can see i can save it as a
pdf if i want to
and if i click ok it's going to save to
my desktop or location of my
choosing and then i can go back and look
at it in that format at a later time
so that's the export feature available
to you
in analytics again if you you could save
it as well
or you can export it okay some other
reports under acquisition
if you're running google ads note that
you can connect google ads to analytics
and this is key
because now i can see how many
people are coming from google ads to my
website
and are they converting now this is
important because with google ads i'm
actually
paying for the click so you can see here
i'm running
a report based on campaign data so i
could see
what campaigns are driving traffic how
much i'm paying
per click and you can see on average i'm
paying
34 cents per click and then more
importantly i want to be able to see
if they're converting so you can see
i've spent
eight hundred and ten dollars over the
last 30 days
and received 858 in revenue
so you want to make sure that you link
up your google ads account to your
google analytics account
for this very reason you want to be able
to see
how your google ads campaigns perform
once the users get to your website
and so i want to see if they're engaging
and i want to see if they're converting
so there are all sorts of reports under
google ads
so you can look at it by keywords by
search queries
by hour of the day if you're running
display campaigns you can look at
display targeting so there's all sorts
of reports under google ads you just
have to link it up and you link it up
under the admin
now there are other reports that you can
look at so if i go to campaigns
i can look at all campaigns so if you're
running
all sorts of different types of
campaigns whether that be
on facebook whether it be email
whether that be you know other types of
advertising
let's just say twitter or instagram
you're going to be able to see those
campaigns here
and that's under all campaigns and again
you'll be able to see
the campaign name and you'll be able to
see metrics associated with those
campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you run an e-commerce platform or if you
have goals set up
so you'll be able to look at how your
campaigns
are not one not only driving traffic but
two
are they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior
so behavior reports are going to
actually
show you how users behaved
once they got to your website once they
landed on a page
on your website how did they behave so
when we looked at audience
we got a sense of who is coming with
acquisition we get a sense of
how the traffic got to our website did
they come from organic
direct social etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure
how that traffic behave once they landed
on a page on our website
and so if i go to overview under
behavior
now i'm looking at this graph here it's
showing me how many page views i've had
and a page view is simply once a page is
viewed it's counted as a page view so if
a user comes to my site
they're initiating a session and if they
look at a page
then that page is going to have a page
view okay so
a user can look at a page multiple times
in a session
and every time they look at that page
it's going to count as a page view
so here i can see in this graph how many
page views i've had
again over the last 30 days and if i
look
further at my overview report i can see
the specific pages
and how many pages they've had and i can
also look
at some other metrics okay the average
bounce rate
the average time on page i can look at
the exit rate
which means how many people actually
exited or the percentage of people who
exited from that page
so i can dig deeper into my behavior
reporting so if i click on
site content and i click on all pages
then i'm going to look at a report
by page this is my dimension this is
what i'm measuring
my page and now i can see how many page
views
each page had over the last 30 days now
note you also have something called
unique page views
so unique page use is equivalent to one
per session
in other words if a user came to my site
and looked at the home page then the
home page is going to have
one unique page view and one page view
now if the user in that same
session looks at other pages then every
page that user looks at is going to have
one unique page view
however if the user goes back to a
to the same page in the same session
then
it's still going to be one unique page
for you but in this case the home page
if they look at the home page a second
time
then the home page is going to have two
page views if they look at the home page
five times in one session then the home
page is gonna have five total page views
and one unique page view okay so that's
why unique pages
is equivalent to one per session where
page uses accumulation of how many times
the page was viewed
in the same session so in other words
you're always going to have
more page views than unique pages okay
so this gives me a sense of
how my page is performed so again i can
look at total page views
and then engagement so ideally what you
want to do with a report like this
is if a user is not engaging on the page
then that should tell you something
about the page itself if they're not
engaging if the bounce rate's high
if the time on page is low if the exit
percentage of exit rate is high
then you probably want to do something
with that page
now these are all pages but if i jump
down to landing pages
my landing page report is showing me how
many people
actually landed on that page and so here
i can see
under my landing page report i can see
the home page had 36 000 17
sessions in the last 30 days that's how
many people
landed on the home page so here i can
see
71 percent were news sessions meaning
that i had a lot of new users who landed
on the homepage in fact
25 000 or 52
of the people who landed on the home
page were new
i could see the balance rates about 42
percent
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about
4.5 pages per session and spent about
three minutes on the site
and the one thing i like about the
landing page report
is they can also see whether that
particular page in this case the home
page
did it help contribute to a goal or
conversion
and in this case i can see of those 36
000 sessions i had 22
transactions totaling 1200 in revenue
and that's an e-commerce conversion rate
of 0.06
so the home page over the last 30 days
contributed to
0.06 percent of the revenue so
this gives you an idea of when somebody
lands on your website
and they land on a page is that page
helping to
move that person along meaning are they
not bouncing and is that page helping to
move people
towards converting and so that's what
the landing page in effect allows us to
measure
is the engagement and in this case we're
measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under behavior
including site speed so site speed to me
is an important report to look at just
like the mobile report
to me site speed's important because
what google analytics does
is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they
sampled 2 835 page views
and of that sample they came back and
said
the average page load time is about
four seconds now ideally you want to
keep it as quick as possible
i would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other
factors involved with page load time the
browser you're using
the country that you're actually
browsing that page from might not have
the best infrastructure you name
may not even be on the best internet
network
meaning you're on a cell network or the
wi-fi is not that great
or you can be on a page that just has a
lot of images or
a lot of code that may slow it down so
there are other factors involved
and so what google analytics does is
show you what those factors are
so here i can see by browser what the
average load
time is if i want to look at country i
could see
what country is contributing to the low
time
now the great thing about the site speed
report
is if i go to speed suggestions okay
what speed suggestions
is going to do is it's going to show me
the page
load time by page and then it's actually
going to
provide a link where i can actually
click on
to get suggestions on increasing the
page
load time so for example i can look at
this particular page here
this google redesign shop by brand
slash youtube page line number five if i
look at line number five i can see the
average load time of this page is eight
seconds almost nine
seconds okay that's an eternity to some
people
now notice this link next to it so
google's recommending
seven total suggestions so if i click on
seven
total what it's actually gonna do it's
going to open up a new window
and it's going to open up another google
report called page speed insights
and page speed insights is going to give
me some information
about what i can do to create correct
correct
the page load of that particular page so
look at this site speed report it's
important because there is a correlation
between
site speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between
page load time and a page ranking
organically on
search so page load times very important
it's so important
that i'm even going to save it so i'm
going to click save and click on speed
site speed suggestions as my name and
click ok
and now that report is going to be saved
under customization
under save reports let's jump from
behavior
to conversions now conversion reporting
is
arguably the most important section
in google analytics because what the
conversions reporting allows us to do
is see how people are converting
or if they're not converting on our
website
and so in google analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals
now you have the opportunity to set up
20 goals
in your google analytics view and so to
set up a goal
okay so you're going to click on admin
and under the view you're going to see
goals
and so if you don't even have goals the
first step is to create goals
and so you have four different goal
types and analytics so you have
pages per session so how many pages per
session
is so if your goal is set to say three
or two if somebody actually looked at
two
or three pages per session it's going to
count as a goal okay so if i look here
i can see i have pages per session set
at 10.
so that means that if a user came to the
site
looked at more than 10 pages per session
then it's going to
count as a goal another goal type is
destination so destination means that if
somebody actually went to a specific
page
then it's going to count as a goal and
in this case
i can see here that the goal is set to
this particular page here
and so when somebody actually lands on
that page it's going to count as a goal
now there are two other goal types we
can look at one
is duration so just like pages per
session
in our previous example if somebody
looked at 10 pages per
session it's gonna count as a goal with
duration it's based on time
so in this particular case if you set up
a duration goal
and the duration is set to say one
minute and 30 seconds then that means if
a user comes to my website
and they spend at least one minute and
30 seconds
then it's going to count as a goal okay
and then the fourth
type of goal in google analytics is an
event-based goal so when you set up
event
tracking you could turn that event into
a goal
so if somebody clicks on say the submit
button of a form
you can turn that event into a goal
so here you can see the category equals
contact form
so you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal
and in this case this event is turned
into a goal so anytime
somebody fires this event it's going to
count as a goal
so you have four different goal types in
google analytics you have pages per
session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure
goals under conversions so now if i look
at goals overview
i can be able to see how many total goal
completions i've had
so if i want to look at it by goal i can
just choose the goal
option here so if i want to look at for
example
goal 2 engaged users this was the pages
per session
i can see that i had a conversion rate
of 10
meaning that i had 7 000
of all the users who came to the website
7 000
gold completions meaning 7106
users looked at 10 pages or more on my
website and so that's how you want to be
able to measure
whether users wherever they're coming
from whoever they are
whatever pages they look at you want to
be able to look at the conversion
reports to see if they're actually
converting
based on the goals you've set up whether
that's pages per session
duration destination or event goal
conversion tracking reports can help you
measure who is actually converting and
the great
thing about google analytics here is
that i can actually see
by segment so the default segment in a
segment
is just looking at a specific user
set so the default segment is always all
users
however i can choose a different segment
so if i want to choose instead of all
users if i want to choose mobile
traffic i can select mobile traffic hit
apply
so i'm actually now looking at a subset
of data i'm looking at mobile traffic
so if all the mobile users have come to
my site
i can see 1400 engaged or looked at
10 pages or more okay and that's a 7
conversion rate so the great thing about
google analytics is you have the
opportunity to set up four different
goal types
okay based on those goal types you can
go to goals
overview and look at the conversion rate
of each goal but you can also change the
segment
of that particular goal to see who
exactly
it okay another report i like under
conversions
is the multi-channel funnel report so if
i click on multi-channel
funnel basically what this allows me to
do is see how different
channels work together to convert so
remember the channel reporting we looked
at
under acquisition here i can see now how
different channels
work together to drive the conversion so
if i look at three channels direct
organic and referral i can see all three
together
drive two percent of the conversions if
i look at direct and referral
twelve and a half percent if i look at
direct and organic
twelve point two four percent so i can
see how
different channels work together and so
if i look at top conversion paths as an
example
i can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example i can see
over the last 30 days
that my top channel grouping was
direct times two meaning that somebody
came to the website directly
meaning they typed in the url in the
browser or they bookmarked it and came
to the site
okay they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination
is my top conversion combination of the
last
30 days my second best conversion
grouping is organic search and direct
meaning that
a user came to the website via organic
search
first did not convert and then came back
via direct the second time and converted
so basically what analytics does
is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website
via referral or referring website and
converted
then the referring website's gonna get
the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so
a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search
but that traffic may not convert the
first time around
for a number of different reasons
whether it could be brand recognition
price shopping reading content whatever
the case
analytics is able to measure if that
channel
actually did contribute at a later point
and in this case we could see
organic search drove traffic that didn't
convert but that traffic came back
a second time via direct and did convert
so that's our second
best channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling report
top conversion pass to me is a good
report to look at
so you can actually see not only our
channels work together but you can see
sources and mediums and campaigns and
how
all that all those different campaigns
from different sources
work together to convert so that's just
a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in
analytics there's so many that we
haven't even gotten to yet so my advice
if you look at the demo report you can
get a feel for each of these reports
under each section whether that be
audience acquisition
behavior or conversions take a look at
these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use
to improve your website performance for
this particular webinar we're going to
jump
into google analytics directly and spend
all of our time there because it's about
learning practical applications so goals
are important
goals uh let me just say this goals are
in analytics something that should be
aligned
with your business and we call goals
that are aligned with your business
kpis are key performance indicators so
it's very important as a precursor that
you know how to set up
goals in google analytics because if
you're using google analytics
you want to measure everything against a
goal
so without further ado let's jump right
into google analytics
so if i go to google analytics and i log
in
okay what i want to do is go
down to admin click on admin here
and admin will take you to basically a
screen that looks like this where you
have a
account column you have your property
column and then you have your view
column
now the view column is where you're
going to go
to set up goals okay so every view
in every property has up to
20 goals okay so by default
in analytics you're going to have at
least one view
for your property so if i have a
property i'm gonna have at least one
view but if i happen to set up multiple
views like you see
here then i know for every view i set up
i have 20 goals to work with so where
are those goals so under the view
i'm going to click on goals and now i
can see
i have 20 at my disposal now you can see
here
by clicking on the recording column i
can see i have
in this particular property this
particular view
i have five goals that are active so you
can use up to 20 but you don't have to
have
20 active okay you can have
one active two active my recommendation
at least
have one goal again when you set up a
goal you're going to measure
everything in analytics against that
goal
okay so in this case we have five
particular goals we're measuring
so we have five active out of 20
total so if i don't no longer want to
use a goal
i could simply just turn it off if i
want to continue using it just turn it
on
okay it's that simple you could turn on
and off goals
so here i already have five set up so
if you want to set up a new goal the one
thing you need to know
in google analytics is in order to set
up a new goal
okay you need to have edit access
at least the view level i would say at
the property level
so you want to make sure whoever is in
charge of google analytics for your
organization
or if you're in charge okay you simply
just want to go to user management
and user management you want to make
sure the email address
you're using to log into google
analytics
has at least edit permissions so you're
going to need
edit permissions to add new goals
so i have edit permissions i'm going to
go to goals
and i want to set up a new goal but
before we jump in and set up a new goal
what is it that we want to achieve
that's
really the question we want to ask
ourselves what is
the goal of the website well if it's
somebody downloading something
okay are you measuring that download via
an event
okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download
so if they submit that form submission
is that the goal
do you have an e-commerce site is
somebody purchasing something
so these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal
what is it that i'm trying to measure
now when you actually
do go to set up a goal you're going to
click on the red
cta button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you
okay you can see them here okay if
you're somebody's registering online or
creating an account
or reading review downloading something
sharing something you could choose all
of these options here
what i normally do is choose custom
99 of the time i'm just going to choose
custom
it doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just
a template is basically some free
pre-filled configurations
but my recommendation is always just go
with custom
you want total control over how to set
up your goal
so we already have in mind what type of
goal we want to set up
so for example if somebody goes to
fill out a form submission and they go
to a thank you page after that
well what's the url of that thank you
page we want to be able to track
how many people go to that page because
we know
if somebody does type in or fill in a
form submission and goes to that page we
know
that they filled out the form and so for
example
if i go to continue i'm going to name my
goal
first so i'm going to say thank you page
as an example notice analytics is
assigning an id so notice this is goal
id
15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available
in analytics and so what analytics does
is they group goals together
so one through five six through 10 11
through 15
16 through 20 into goal sets
so for example goals 16 through 20
is part of goal set four and why does
google analytics
combine these goals into different goal
sets well
because it's easier to ma measure and
look at data
by goal sets so for example if i jump
into any report here
if i go to all traffic channels and i
want to measure
how many goals by channel i can look at
it by goal set
so if i have goal set 1 selected then i
know
any goal i have active in there between
goal id 1
through goal id 5 i'm going to be able
to see those goals in goal set one
and now i'm going to be able to measure
every goal i have active and goal set
one
against the channel so if i choose goal
set 2 whatever goals are active there
goal set 3 etc notice i don't have any
goals
16 through 20 active that are in goal
set for
therefore i don't have that option
available to me
so back to admin bottom left navigation
again goals okay we want to measure
somebody going to the thank you page
we have edit access we're going to
choose
custom as our goal set up we're going to
type in a goal name i'm just going to
say thank you
okay this is goal 15. now this is the
important part
google analytics has four different goal
types
destination duration pages per session
or screens per session so screens per
session is related to mobile
because google analytics measures mobile
app activity and then you have an event
so we're going to cover
all four of these but for the sake of
this simple example i'm going to choose
destination
why because if somebody goes to that
thank you page
we're going to go ahead and put in the
thank you page
as the goal the goal url so
for example destination is my choice i'm
going to click continue
now this is where i'm going to put the
url so if my url is just simply
thank you.html i can just go ahead and
put thank you.html
or if it's just thank you then i can
just do thank you
depends on the website depends on the
uri
structure so whatever that url is that's
what you're going to put in
and when you're done you can verify it
so what google analytics does is
actually
will verify over the last seven days if
anybody's actually gone to that
particular page
so if we click verify we can see zero
percent conversion rate so that tells us
that if this is the correct url then
we've had zero percent people go to that
page
this is just an example however if you
didn't see
a conversion then you might want to make
sure you check
the url here that you put in and if you
do see a conversion rate
then you know it's working so google
analytics actually has options
so we're saying thank you is equal to so
the destination url
is equal to thank you or thank you.html
or
thank you.esp or whatever that thank you
page is
okay you do have options so if you have
a long
url you could say begins with and you
could say begins with say
thank you so this is the logic we're
gonna say hey if anybody goes to a url
that begins
with thank you then count it as a goal
or you could say
equals to so if anybody goes to a url
that equals two thank you
then count it as a goal you have one
more option here regular expression so
google analytics understands the
language of regular expressions
so regular express expressions are just
special
characters used to communicate with
google analytics in order to hone
in on exactly what you're trying to
track so we can always say you know
starts with
or ends with so we can you know use
characters like the dollar sign
ends with or begins with so we can
always do that
so you can use regular expressions as
well
if you're familiar with regular
expressions if you're not then you don't
have to use them
but there are special characters where
that you can insert
in that are used as regular expression
so if you're not familiar with regular
expression
don't choose that option you can choose
the other option of
equals to or begins with now note that
on all three of these options i didn't
put the domain
so if my domain is ama dash
foundation.org
slash and then thank you i don't need to
put the domain because analytics is
already knows what domain we're tracking
so you don't have to put in
the domain here when you're entering in
in this case the google url so you can
omit
the domain so when you put in that url
you know that you have three options to
work with
and then you always always want to
verify
that goal url you always want to verify
it because
if you see zero percent conversion and
in this case of
the last seven days then that should
tell you something either your goal is
not set up correctly
or you just don't have any conversions
either way you want to double check that
now when it comes to the destination url
goal
you do have an option here for funnel so
if i turn
on funnel then that means i have the
ability
to track how people went through my
funnel
so if i have a cart and i want to be
able to check how many people go in
and out of the cart then i have the
option of
adding specific pages as part of the
cart
so we could say you know step one which
is
basically cart we could say step two
is billing information that could be
slash billing
we could see step three is shipping
information slash shipping
and then step four could be you know
confirm
and that could be slash confirmation so
whatever your url
structure is for your cart and it
doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all i'm doing is putting a
series of steps
with urls as each step and why do i want
to do that because i can then track
how many people go through my funnel
that i've created
okay so here i could see this is my
funnel that i've created
for this particular goal okay and the
funnel is only available for the
destination url
so the funnels available if you want to
see traffic through the goal
okay and how people go through the
funnel and where they drop off
now you have an option here to make the
first step require
so if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel
through the first step only now if i
turn that off
then i'm measuring the funnel through
each step meaning that i can measure
people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required
the first step then i'm only measuring
traffic as it
enters in the top of the funnel so you
have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals
you do have a value so if somebody
did actually convert okay google
analytics is going to count it as a
conversion and you can assign a value
so if you're not an e-commerce website
then you may want to think about
assigning value
if you are an e-commerce website then
analytics
has the ability to track e-commerce
revenue
for your website so you don't need to
add a value but in this case
let's just say your non-profit
organization
and you're collecting donations and on
average over the past year
every donation that somebody contributed
was equal to five dollars
well you can just go ahead and put five
dollars in there
as the value for that goal so that means
that
if somebody did go to in this example
slash thank you and convert analytics is
going to count it as a goal
and then assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're not
e-commerce
if you're say a non-profit like this
organization
or your b2b and you want to track some
value
then you have that option there so with
the destination url goal you have the
option of adding a funnel
with all goal types you have the option
of adding a value
all goal types and we're going to go
through the rest of them you have the
option
of verifying that goal so that's the
structure of setting up a goal
destination url is just one goal
type we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in google
analytics there are four
goal types again destination is one of
them
with destination as you do have the
option with all goal types
is you have to be able to choose your
logic here so we're going to cover that
with the other three but just know when
you set up a destination url goal
you have the option of adding a funnel
now when you actually do set up a
funnel what's going to happen is
analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
where do you
look for that funnel information well
you want to get out of admin
you want to go to the left side
navigation you want to click
on conversions then goals then funnel
visualization
so based on the funnel you set up you're
going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice
on this particular funnel we don't have
the first step required
why because i could see traffic as it
goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so
here i can see the first step is the
store front page
so over this particular period of time i
had
84 sessions enter the storefront page
so out of those 84 i can see 21
left the storefront page 63
went on to the next step in the final
which is the cart page i can then see 24
people went on to the cart page directly
and five exited the site altogether okay
so
that gave me 87 total and from 87
i saw that 82 went on to the next page
with the next step what analytics does
is they give you a percentage
so in the first step we had 63 move on
to the car
page out of 84 that's 75 percent
so from the cart page to the create your
account page
we had 94 move on so
we didn't have anybody entering the
create your account page we didn't have
anybody
leave the create your account page so if
82
82 create your account and then we have
82
move on to the payment page so that's
100
okay we have one exit so if it 81
that proceeded to be on the payment page
which was purchased
so 81 of 82 is 98
and we started with 84 so
that gave us plus the 24 that we
accumulated along the way
so that gave us a 75 percent
funnel conversion rate so 75
of the people who entered in the funnel
went on
to purchase okay so don't be confused
with the
overall ecommerce conversion rate so 75
is the funnel conversion rate the
overall conversion rate for this
particular goal is
18.45 over this particular period of
time
why because that takes into account all
sessions that have won to the website
so 18 of all traffic
went on to convert but those that did go
into the funnel
75 converted so that's a look at the
funnel so if you set up a funnel
that's what it's gonna look like you
have the option to
measure everything from step one and on
or measure
as traffic goes in and out of the funnel
so the purpose of this
is we're gonna be able to see where
traffic drops off
how effective our funnel is what pages
we need to address
in that funnel okay so that's the whole
point of the funnel
and the funnel is available with the
destination url goal
so if i go back to admin if i go back to
goals under the view
i can actually see what that funnel
looks like
so here we chose regular expression so
this
is what the url is okay you can see our
funnel
in each of the steps we have set up
notice we're using regular expressions
here
and then if we verify this goal we could
see
over the past seven days 19
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working
in this particular with this particular
goal because we do have a conversion
rate okay so that's
the destination url goals let's now
talk about the other three types of
goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about is pages per session
so if you're not sure what type of goal
to set up
for your website at the very least you
should try and set up
either duration related goal or pages
per session
related goal so let's talk about the
pages per session
so basically what this goal is going to
allow us to measure
is for example if we set the goal to
three pages per session
then we're going to be able to measure
if how many people went to the site and
looked at three pages per session so
let's take a look at that goal so if i
open up the goal
here i can see three pages per session
is what we're naming it
so basically what we're asking analytics
to do is
anything greater than two pages which
would be
three and beyond count as a goal
so if anybody comes to the site looks at
more than
two pages three pages or more then
it's going to count as a goal and so
here we can verify it
so if we verify it over the last seven
days we could see
a 4.12 conversion rate and that tells me
that four percent of my traffic over the
last seven days
looked at at least three pages or more
so you're probably asking yourself well
what number should i put in for the
actual
variable so in this case we see two well
what you want to do is you want to look
at
on average let's just say year to date
you want to make sure you have
statistical significance so you want to
look at a period of time so if you go to
analytics
go to audience okay and then if you go
to overview
and if i change my date range to year to
date
i could see on average right now i have
1.21
pages per session so that's on average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page
we don't want to make our goal two pages
we want to make it three so we want to
be able to
basically measure at a higher rate
okay why do we want to measure at a
higher rate because if 1.21 is the
average
then two pages per session really isn't
moving the needle so what we really want
to do
is get people to stay on the site longer
look at pages
more during their session so look at
more pages
and so we want to be able to see what
segment of the audience is looking at
more pages what channels driving traffic
that's looking at more pages
what pages are contributing to more
pages per session
so the whole idea is you want to hone in
on what your goal is and see what's
working
and then see what's not working so you
can make adjustments
the whole idea beyond google analytics
is to
improve website performance and so if
our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just two it may
not be good enough so in this case
you know we want to up the bar a little
bit so we're gonna choose three
now you can choose four or five that's
perfectly fine
just know if your average is 1.2 i
wouldn't choose one page per session
as my goal and i probably wouldn't
choose two so i'd set the bar a little
bit higher
now the third goal type available in
google analytics is
also engagement related and that's
duration so just like pages per session
we can measure how long somebody stays
on the website
and we could set up a goal for that so
in this case
i have a goal set for one minute 30
seconds
so my goal type is duration so if i
click continue
then basically i'm asking analytics in
this case
anybody who stays more than one minute
and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds
you want to look at that average so if
you go back to audience
overview here i can see a minute and
seven so
do we want a minute and 30 maybe we
could do that maybe we can go with two
minutes
so again the whole point is you want to
set the bar
a little bit higher than what the
average is and so here i could see over
the last seven days if i
verify this particular goal i can see
eight percent
of my traffic over the last seven days
stayed on the site at least one minute
and 31 seconds
okay they stayed greater than one minute
and 30. and so the whole point is you
can hone in because this is a goal
i can go in this is goal okay this is a
goal here
and so i could see that this is goal 13.
so now i can go to acquisition as an
example i can go
to channels as an example since this is
a goal
this is gold 13 so that would be in goal
set three
so i can actually see what channel is
basically
driving that goal okay in other words
what
channel is driving traffic that is
staying on the side at least
one minute and 30 seconds and so that's
the whole
idea behind goals so likewise for pages
per session
we can go into channels and here i can
see
we've have a over this period of time
to date pages per session we have three
percent conversion rate and here i could
see
for example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here i can see social
media has a 10 percent
so i could see that or people coming
from organic search
are staying on the site longer or
they're looking at more
pages than any other channel so
just like duration or destination or any
goal you set up
you can measure that goal against any
dimension
just because it's engagement doesn't
mean you can't
you absolutely can and so the whole
point of engagement really goals
is to figure out what's driving traffic
to the site but
what traffic is engaging so you want to
be able to pinpoint that
so you can improve website performance
now the fourth
goal type available in google analytics
is an event so if you click on new goal
you close custom click continue you have
the option
to choose an event so an event
is something that you can measure on
your website
that analytics can't measure by default
so if you want to measure
pdf downloads or clicks on buttons or
clicks on play buttons on a video or
click on a submit button or click on an
external link i mean you
can measure pretty much anything with an
event
then you want to be able to turn that
event
into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure
a particular event that happens on the
website so in order to do so
we need to identify that event so if i
go to
for example this particular website here
and i want to measure how many times
somebody clicks on
the donate now button well if i met i
can measure that as an event
so when you set up an event in analytics
you have to
actually assign a category and an action
for that event so that's the first thing
you need to do
when you identify an event related goal
first you need to set up the event
in order to set up the event you need to
assign a category
in action okay so once you identify what
you want to track as an event
on your website you're actually going to
go in a tag manager or have your
webmaster go into tag manager
and set up a tag and in that tag
they're going to assign that particular
category in action
and so here you can see we have this set
up
our category is named donate now and our
action
is click and that's what we want to do
we want to measure
how many people click on that donate now
button so anytime somebody does that
then the category donate now is going to
appear
in analytics with the action click so
when you actually do set up an event
you can go into analytics and you could
test that event so if i go to the
website
and i click donate now okay the reason
why i have this as an event
is because i'm taking to a third party
website
to handle the donations so here i can go
into analytics and now i can see
a category is being fired for header
donate with the action click
so that's my category and that's my
action
so that category in action is what is
firing
after somebody clicks on the donate now
button
so if i want to turn this event into a
goal
i can easily do that now that i've set
up the event now that i've identified
the category in action
i want to go back to admin and
set up the event with these parameters
in place
so just turns out we already have the
goal set up so let's go through how
this goal was set up so first we chose
custom
we chose event we gave it a name so as a
best practice when you actually set up a
goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
i would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals and you're reporting
you know it's an event
so i'm going to click continue and now
that i've
actually have set up the event already
in google tag manager
i've given it a category i give it an
action okay see here you can see
we have a regular expression set up so
anything
with the header donate or donate is
going to fire
this goal so over the last seven days i
have a 0.81
conversion rate okay i could have easily
put in
equals two and put in whatever the
action what or the category which is
donate now
or i could have put action equals click
i could have done that as well so let me
show you another example here
so if i do this custom continue
event donate now here's my goal id
it's going to be an event so all i need
to do is put in the category in action
so donate now and then click so
that's all i have to do and that's my
goal so i can verify it
okay to see if anybody's fired it and
basically
that's what i need to do to turn that
event
into a goal okay so you need to set up
for an event
first you need to identify the event set
it up in google tag manager
which is another platform and once
you've done that
then you have your category in action
once you have your category in action
you're again going to go into analytics
and then simply put in that category and
action into the appropriate fields
to set up your event related goal now
all events don't have to be turned into
a goal
if you actually do set up an event and
you're not worthy
of a goal meaning it's not a kpi
or doesn't align with your business
goals
well don't fret you can always just go
to behavior
okay you can always go to events you can
always go to overview
and measure your events that way so here
you can see
all of our events that are fired now we
do have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business
then we want to make sure we convert
that particular event
into a goal okay if it's not important
for example somebody's just clicking on
a social button
then you don't necessarily have to turn
that event into a goal if you don't want
to
know that it's sitting here under events
under behavior
so the point i'm trying to make here if
it's important to your business
and you're already tracking it as an
event via google tag manager
then feel free to turn it into a goal
all you need is that category
all you need is that action and so so
one final note on that event related
goal
just like any other goal you can add a
value okay
so if i have an event set up i can
choose
to add a value here or in google tag
manager if i've assigned a value
to that event so if i go back to the
actual event
in google tag manager you can see i have
a value set up for one dollar
then i can just go into analytics and
say you know what i already have the
value added
so go ahead and use the value added in
google tag manager okay so i'm going to
choose yes
now if i choose no i have the option to
add
the value here just like i would with
any other goal so
just keep that in mind you can add a
value to
any goal type with an event related goal
you can add the value right into
the tag in google tag manager just as
i've done here
so remember when you actually set up
your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in
and measure any dimension against
that particular goal so here i can see e
newsletter sign
ups by channel i can go into another
goal set here i can see
contact form submissions okay i can see
what particular channels driving contact
form submissions
okay so just know that you can align a
goal
against any dimension so if you have
e-commerce
you don't have to set up for goal for
that that's separate
but if you want to take a look at your
goals and analytics
on its own you can just go to
conversions goals
overview here i can actually get
a good sense of how my goals are
performing
over a period of time so again if i
choose
for example year to date now i can see
based on the goals i've set up how many
total goal completion
value which takes into account the value
we've added into these goals
okay the total conversion rate and here
i can see it broken down
by the goal i actually have set up and i
can see it by
page or i could see it by source and
media so i could see google organic is
driving the most gold completions
then google cpc direct and then
i could see some others in here as well
contributing to goals
now i do want to point your attention to
another report
in google analytics that does take into
account goals and that's multi-channel
funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels
if i go to assisted conversions
i can actually see what channel in this
example
is assisting with the conversions i've
set up
and so what do we mean by assisted
conversions well
that means that if a channel
let's just say organic search drove
traffic to the website
and that traffic didn't convert when it
arrived at the website and left
but it came back a week later via
another channel let's just say email
and when they came back via email they
did convert
during that session well what analytics
does is they give
an assist to organic search because they
help drive the traffic to the website so
it's similar to the game of basketball
if i have the ball and i pass it to my
colleague and my colleagues the one who
scores because they had the ball last
well they get the credit for the point
i.e the conversion
but i get an assist and so analytics
works the same way
they're always going to give credit to
the last click
or direct conversion but they will give
credits
to the channel in this case that
assisted with the conversion
so that's under assisted conversion and
that's based on the goals you have set
up
you can highlight any particular goal
here
if i want to hone in on say to donate
clicks
only then i'm going to be able to see
what contributed
to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that i think is
important
so after you set up your goals you can
actually see
what channels in this particular example
help to drive
conversions again this is year to date
so i can see
all the different combinations of
channels that work together
to contribute to a conversion so again i
can choose a specific
goal or i can choose all my goals
so those two reports are under
multi-channel funneling there's also
another report that i think is good
that's time lag
meaning how long did it actually take
somebody to
convert so here you can see most of our
conversions 265
year-to-date happened on the day
somebody arrived on the website
but i could see i did get some
conversions a day later two days later
etc
so you have time lag top conversion pass
assistant conversions
they're all under multi-channel
funneling and they're all available
after you set up at least one goal and
so
if you're not sure what goal to set up
okay don't fret
you can always at least set up an
engagement related goal
so that's available to you duration
pages per session
you also have destination and event
tracking and they're all
available to you you have 20 available
per view now if you're not quite sure
exactly what type of goal to set up
there is an option available
in analytics and that's the gallery so
you can always
import a goal from the gallery so in
other words
we could take a look at what other
people
have set up in terms of goals so you
just have to click on the button import
from gallery
and i'll take you to the gallery and
you'll be able to see
what other goals others have set up
today we're going to talk about
how to set up event tracking in google
analytics so let's get started
so many of you out there have a website
similar to the one i'm looking at now
this is a non-profit that i work with
i'm a foundation
and like this website and probably like
your website you probably have some
interactivity on there
that needs to be tracked for example
buttons
uh if you have buttons like this one
that says donate or
newsletter sign up or there's a pdf
download
or a video that needs to be you know
tracked
based on the amount of people who click
on the play button so i mean all sorts
of inter
activity on a website have you ever
wondered how to track that
well there is a way to track that
because by default
google analytics can't track
interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked
so if you have buttons and videos and
things of that nature that you want to
attract
well you're going to need event tracking
and if you're in analytics and you're
always
wandering around the data and you happen
to find yourself under events
well if you want events on your website
and you want data to populate under
behavior
top events you're going to need to set
up event tracking so event tracking
is a two-part process and we're going to
talk about that two-part process
the first part of that is to identify
what you want to track
okay so if we go back to our example
website here
i'm a foundation again we noted there's
a lot to track here
we gotta donate now bob we got a
newsletter sign up we have some social
icons
okay we got a donate now button here we
got a play button
here got all sorts of interactivity you
know we got a button here that says
you know purchase tickets for an
upcoming event i can go throughout the
website
and find different buttons and things to
to track let me just say this there's no
shortage of what you can track
on your website with event tracking
so event tracking is just basically in
layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
google analytics by default is only
going to track
pageview data meaning how somebody got
to your website
what page they looked at how long they
stayed on that page
what page they left from more or less
their timing
how long somebody stays on the website
and what pages they look at so
there's more to a website than just how
long somebody stayed on a page
and so in this example we want to be
able to track
everything here not just the donating
album but everything because
once you get the hang of event tracking
then it's very easy to set up
okay so step one identify what you want
to track okay
so there's a lot we want to track we're
just going to use one example
to start off with and that's going to be
this donate now button okay
so this donate now button we want to
track
now we have a newsletter sign up we have
facebook
and and that's fine you could track all
that but for the sake
of going through a step-by-step process
today
let's just focus on the donate now
button let's focus on the donating now
but and then we'll come back and start
tracking these other things but this is
what we want to track to start out with
okay
so step one identify what you want to
track
now when it comes to tracking events on
a website
you want to identify those events so we
did that by choosing this donate now
button
now once we identify what we want to
track
we need to assign two parameters
for that event so with event tracking
you have
three parameters but one is actually
optional so you have two
main mandatory parameters that you have
to assign
to everything you want to track on your
website and that's the category
and then the action so event label
or label is the third parameter but
again that's
optional okay so basically when we
identify an event on our website we want
to assign it a category
and an action okay so why do we want to
assign it a category and an action
because
when we're in analytics under behavior
under events
top events we could see we have
different categories here
and we have different actions we have
different labels so if i click on any
one of these
dimensions i'm going to be able to see
some of the parameters i've entered in
for previous events i'm tracking okay so
the whole idea is you want to be able to
group different events together into a
category
and assign an action and assign a label
to it that's really what you're doing
you're just
grouping and identifying the events
you're trying to track
and so in this case i have this donate
now button
sitting in the header okay in fact i
have a lot of things sitting in the
header so
if i wanted to and i want to track all
these buttons i can create a category
called
header and then if i track all these
buttons all these buttons can sit in
that same
category if i wanted to or i can create
a
separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you
how you organize your categories because
basically all you're doing
is giving a name to what you're trying
to track and the name
is equivalent to a category so in this
case the donate now button's very
important i'm just going to call it
category header donate now i need to
give an action
to each category and so in this case i'm
just going to say click because that's
what the action is doing it's it's
somebody's taking the action of clicking
now if it's a video and it's a play
button
i can assign an action of play it's
up to you whatever you name these
parameters
you just need to be organized and
methodical about what you name it that's
all
and so in this case header donate and
then click
okay and so that's our category in
action and so that's clearly step two so
step one
identify what you want to track step two
assign
a category action and or label
but remember label is optional so if i
go back in analytics here i could see
some categories
and if i click on action i can see some
actions that i've named
now step three so we've identified in
step one what we want to track
we've assigned a category in action so
step
three is going into google tag manager
to set up the event okay so if you're
not familiar with google tag manager
then you can easily just you know do a
google
search for google tag manager and
basically you'll have all sorts of
information on it there's a good video
overview
of tag manager here that you can watch
so
tag manager basically is
what we want to use to set up event
tracking now
tag managers use for a lot of different
things but the main thing we're doing
here
is setting up an event for our website
and so i'm logged in to the same email
address i'm using for analytics okay so
now i'm in tag manager and i want to set
up my event
for this donate now button so what do i
need to do
well for every event i want to set up
i need to set up a tag okay so if i go
to tags
i can see i already have some tags set
up and some of these
are events and so when you actually set
up a tag
i recommend having a naming convention
so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it ga
event dash whatever it is we're trying
to set up and so in this case we want to
set up a new tag
for the donate now button on our website
so we're in google tag
manager because tag manager is what's
going to fire that event
so if i click on new okay and i click on
tag configuration
i'm going to choose google analytics and
then i'm going to choose
event as my track type so we want the
data to show up in google analytics
and we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a page view we're tracking an
event
and so now remember in step two
you identified what you want to call
that category you identify what you want
to call that action
and you have some optional parameters
like label so
first things first header donates the
name of our category
and our action is click and if you want
to add in
a label and a value so if you want to
assign a value
you can if you want to add in a label
you can okay those are
optional so you just need to focus on
category and action
and then the last setting here that's
probably worth mentioning
is a non-interaction hit okay
so this is automatically set to false
and why is it set to false because it's
a non-interaction
no that's false we want this event if
somebody clicks on the header donate
to be an interaction so for example if i
land
on this page here and i click on that
donate now button that i'm tracking as
an event
and i actually leave the site because i
have
my settings set to false i want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is not going to count a bounce
if i change it to true so from false to
true
then that means it is going to be a
non-interaction
if somebody lands on the page and if
somebody clicks
on the button so i don't want it to be a
bounce i want it to be an interaction so
my advice is leave it set to false
we're going to choose google analytics
as our setting here this is our variable
for google analytics so in other words
that variable is set to our analytics
property id and more or less that's what
you need to do
to set up the tag okay you need to
in step two identify the category in
action
and or label and or value now value can
be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign one
any time that event fires in analytics
it's gonna have a value of
one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set to fall so anytime
the event fires
it's going to count as an interaction
and therefore not count as a bounce
if somebody landed on that page so
that's more or less all you need to do
to set
up the tag in google tag manager
now if somebody else is setting up the
tag for you
then again you want to revert to step
two you want to be able to give that
person
the appropriate category action and or
label
and or value why because you're the one
that's going to be going into google
analytics and you're the one that's
going to have to go to behavior
events top events and look for the
particular
act category in action and or label so
you need to be able to communicate that
information to whomever is setting up
the tag now if it's you
great you already know what it is
because you're entering that information
into tag manager so in this case i'm
going to go ahead
and choose a variable for
my label parameter and why do i want to
do that because
in tag manager i have something at my
disposal called variables
and variables allow you to see
specifically
things that are being tracked so in this
case i choose page path okay
so page path is a url and why did i
choose page path
as my variable for the parameter label
because if somebody does click on the
header donate button
and the header donate button on our
website is on
every page so if i go to the children's
page i'm still going to see
that header donate button and so for me
i want to be able to see what page
somebody clicked on that hit or donate
button and so
this allows me to actually see in google
analytics
what page somebody clicked on the header
donate now button and so now if i go
back to
gtm google tag manager i have a category
i have an action and i have a label
which is a variable
okay so note that in google tag manager
you have a lot of different variables
at your disposal and variables are there
to help you identify specifically
what is being tracked so take a look at
all the variables at your disposal
in tag manager in this example i'm using
page path
so now once you set up your tag pretty
straightforward again
tag types google analytics track type is
event
you are assigning the category action
end or label and or value you're
changing or leaving
the default in place for non-interaction
hit
and then you're choosing the variable
for google analytics
which is your property id so once you've
done that you have a tag
the second part of setting up a tag is
to assign
a trigger to that tag so tag manager
needs to be able to know when to fire
that event
and so here i'm going to look at a
trigger i've
already set up for this particular event
and so if i click on it i'll be able to
see that
what it is is a click on some links not
all links but some
links i'm actually saying hey
google tag manager fire this event
when the click id equals header donate
button
now it just so happens that if somebody
did click
on this donate now button they're gonna
go to
another website in this case
networkforgood.com
so in tag manager i could have
set the trigger to equal url
equal instead of click id i could have
said
url equal networkforgood.com
so that could have been my logic for
my trigger in this case i decided to go
with the click id
and so in this case that button has an
id
associated with it called header donate
button
so if you wanted to use click id for
your event for your button
you could simply just go to the website
you can right click on that button and
click inspect element and so when i
actually inspect the element
i can see now the button here you can
see it's highlighted in the upper pane
and in the lower pane i can see where
it's linking to it's linking to
networkforgood.com
but here you can see if i hone in a
little i could see id
equals header dash donate button so
that's the click
id notice there's also a class i could
have
set the trigger to equal this class or
again i could have set the trigger to
equal
the url or the page that this button is
pointing to i could have chosen any one
of those but i decided to go
with the id so this is the id i chose
and that's the id i have in
my trigger okay so that is what's going
to fire
that event so if somebody clicks on a
button that equals
header dash donate button it's going to
fire that event
which is going to equal category header
donate
action click and then the label is going
to be page path
so now that we've set up our event we
want to test to see if it actually works
so there's two ways to go about testing
an event
and the first way is through google
analytics so
if we go to google analytics and then we
go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so
let's go ahead and go to and test this
and go to the website so if i go here
for example
and i click on amagar alumni
okay so if i click on that you can see
i'm under our family
and if i click on that button then go
back to analytics
and look at real time i should be able
to see this event fire so if i click on
it
i'm going to go to network for good now
if i go back
to analytics here in real time under
real time under events
per second i can see that event firing
category equals header donate the action
equals click
now if i click on the category
here i can see the label the label
remember was page path
and here you can see this event fired on
the r family page which was the page i
was just on
so that's one way to test to see if your
event works and in this case
analytics recognize the event so it
works it fired and so therefore it's
going to show up
under behavior under events you can go
under overview or top events
okay and what am i going to look for in
this case i'm going to look for header
donate
okay if i click on header donate as my
category
i'm going to be able to see my action
and if i click on action
i'll be able to see my label in this
case home page
and then later on when the data
propagates in analytics i'll be able to
see
under label the page that i clicked on
that hit or donate button which is
slash our family okay the second way in
which you can
test to see if an event fires
is if you preview so if i click on
preview and tag manager okay i'm going
to go into preview mode okay
and preview mode allows you to see in
analytics and tag manager and on the
website what
tags are firing so here i could see i'm
in preview mode now so i'm gonna go
to the website and i'm gonna refresh
and in my browser same browser i'm using
for tag manager
i can see the tags that are being fired
on this page already okay because i'm in
preview mode
so here i could see remarketing i could
see
page views i could see google optimize i
could see some tags that are already
firing on this page
now if i click on this button here by
holding down my shift command
and then click on that button i'll be
able to see
that the tag fired in preview mode
there's my event header donate
and i can see it fired so now i can see
it fired
in the preview mode so in addition to
google analytics
in preview mode i could see that that
tag is fired
and i know that it's working so there
you have you have two ways to test
to see if the event fires again you have
real time and analytics
okay so in real time if you just go up
to real time
all you need to do is go down to events
go to your website
click on the button if you see it firing
in real time then you know it works
the second version or second way to test
your event
is through the preview mode okay if you
see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working okay so let's
rehash our steps first step is we want
to be able to
identify what we want to track okay so
it could be this newsletter sign up it
could be click on a facebook
it could be anything we want to be able
to track an image
a click on a cta button whatever we want
to track
identify it second step identify
the category action and label because
that's what's going to show up
in google analytics remember label is
optional
variable or excuse me value is optional
third step
go into tag manager actually set up your
tag
and your trigger so if you set up a tag
and it's an event name it ga-event
that way you can see in your list of
tags in tag manager
what event tracking you have already set
up so when you set up your tag
you set up your trigger your trigger is
based on logic
that can be a url it can be a click id
it can be a class
id whatever you want to use to fire
that event and then once you do that you
want to test it you could test
it in gtm or you could test it in google
analytics
if it doesn't fire you want to tweak
your trigger
if it does fire then great
and then one thing i would recommend is
if you're setting up
various events for your website as a
best practice
what i would recommend is set up a
spreadsheet and in that spreadsheet
you know you want to put a note what's
firing what are you doing to fire
it could be in this case when somebody
clicks on the donate now button in the
header
you want to put the tag name in here the
type okay then you want to
record your category action and label
and then
the great thing about events is you
could turn
those events into goals and that's as
simple as going back into analytics
okay so if i go into analytics and i go
to admin
and i go to goals if you set up a new
goal okay
all you need to do is choose custom
click continue
you're going to choose event as your
goal name
and then from a naming perspective in
google analytics
for your goal i would definitely put
event first
and then click on header donate okay so
if i click now continue
what is my category it's equal to head
or donate
my action is click and so i can verify
to see if this is working and here i can
see
in analytics that the goal would have a
0.22
conversion rate so that tells me that
the goal is working
and i can turn this event into a goal
and when you turn something into a goal
and analytics
then you can measure it across all
dimensions
that's what i would recommend if the
event
is equal to a kpi or business goal
or it's of importance something you
really want to measure
okay if it's just a click say on a
facebook button i wouldn't recommend
setting that up as a goal okay so once
you've set up your event
you've recorded it in your spreadsheet
it's firing
you want to be able to then go back into
behavior
back into events okay you can go to top
events
okay so top events tell you by category
as a default what events are firing or
what category
is firing the most okay so if i choose
my date range
here i can just go to year to date so
here i can see
my header donate button fortunately for
me
has the most total events now notice
in analytics you also see unique events
and so the difference between unique
events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that
somebody can come to your website
initiate a session
and click on that button multiple times
in the same session
so if i go to the alma foundation
website
okay i can click on that donate now
button three or four or five different
times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually
in that session count it once but
accumulate the number of clicks
as a total event for that session so
you're always going to have more total
events
than unique events because in some cases
users may click on the button more than
once in the same session
and so here i can see total events
unique events and if i added a value
to that event i should be able to see it
here so if i added
a dollar as an example to this
particular
event because it had 164 unique events
i should be able to see 164 as my value
but since i see zero that means that i
did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me
how much average i have per event so
it's taking into account
the number of or the value the total
value
divided by the total number of unique
pageviews or sessions and so because i
don't have value i'm not going to have
average value
but here you can see because value is
optional here i can at least see
how many events or how many clicks
i receive for a particular button again
it could be
a video if i clicked on this video as an
example
i can see how many people actually
started it
i could see the unique and the total
events and if i click on label
if i have a label assigned then i'll be
able to see
what page triggered that event so if we
go back
again to our header donate button back
to category if we click on label
as our primary dimension here we can see
the home page
had the most unique events been followed
by the children's page the contact form
etc
so what you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here i could see the home page
has accumulated the most
total events followed by the contact us
so that's
how you would look at the data in google
analytics
under behavior under events and then
under
top events or overview is where you can
start analyzing
your event tracking so first you need to
do
identify it assign a category action
enter label
set up that tag and trigger once you do
that once you test that it's working
this is where you're gonna go to analyze
the data let's start out with
ygtm so let's just say you're sam
and you have your own e-commerce website
and you want to understand
how people are interacting with your
website well sam
today's world of websites contain a lot
of interactivity
everything from videos to pdf downloads
to commenting
to form submissions uh to all sorts of
chat functionality interactivity going
on throughout the website so there's
just a lot
that you need to track outside of just
page views
and so really what gtm does
is they help you track all these things
i just mentioned everything from
somebody clicking on the play button of
a pdf to somebody clicking on the submit
button of a form
to somebody entering in something on a
chat function
so that's what gtm is so why gtm because
it helps us track
all that interactivity so all gtm is is
really allows you to
really place a piece of java code which
is just
script and this script that's added to a
web page
to collect information so that's really
what a tag is it's just some script
that gets put on a web page in order for
you to collect information
like page views clicks etc and they send
it to third party tools
okay so that's what gtm does it it
basically allows you
to take all these tags that collect
information
and you can use them in gta
so if you want to for example collect
how many people you know enter a
chat functionality and start chatting
well you're going to take
that script and you're going to put it
in gtm and gtm will then allow you to
start tracking that information
so that's really what gtm is it just
allows you to put tags
into a container or think of it as a toy
box you have all these toys and you want
to track
or you can put all those those toys or
tags in a toy box or container and we're
going to talk a little bit more about
that
but before we get into gtm let's just
say
you know you're communicating with your
developer and there's a new user request
on your web page and you want to update
the tag
well your developer considering it's
probably a small
update your website is probably gonna
not
um hesitate and is gonna go ahead and
turn around and do it
normally and so normally what happens is
the developer is gonna go to the website
and update the tag
well what if you have a few things that
you wanna track
all those things i mentioned before from
downloads to clicks
to you know somebody checking out to
watching a video
well your webmaster your web developer
is going to go well
hold on a second now all these requests
are going to take time
i need to put them into the work queue
so to speak
well what happens is when they go into
work queue
usually it's going to take some time and
in some cases
you as a marketer need to launch a
campaign
and you want to get that tracking uh
added to the website
in time for the campaign launch so you
want to go ahead and
quickly turn around the tracking for
that particular campaign let's just say
you're launching a campaign
and you're sending people to a landing
page that has a form submission and you
want to be able to track how many people
click on the submit button of that form
submission well
if you need to turn that around your
developer's like well i need to put that
in a work queue
the timing isn't going to always work
out between you and your developer is my
point
and so that's where gtm comes in because
there is a solution update your tags
faster and
that's google tag manager so when we say
gtm
that's what gtm stands for google tag
manager it's a place for you to add tags
quickly and easily so tags remember
are just snippets of code that allow you
to track things on your website
interactively
interactive activity and basically
when you have gtm you can bypass the
webmaster
and do it quickly and easily so that's
what gtm is all about so why
gtm because we just identified two
benefits
one you could track all the
interactivity on your website
and two you can bypass your web
developer or webmaster
and so that's the benefit of gtm so
the benefit you get those tags updated
very quickly
via google tag manager okay so that's
what tag manager is so
what we're going to talk about today is
specifically
what tag manager is and what it does
we're going to list some of the benefits
of tag manager
we're going to show you how it works and
then we're going to show you how to get
started with tag manager
tag manager if you're not familiar with
working with webmasters
and dealing with javascript and tags and
all this jargon is just
new to you today okay well don't fret
sit back we're going to take it slow
this is an introduction into google tag
manager again
let's start out with what is tag manager
so we've already introduced it to some
degree
because we already introduced is a tool
where you can
put all your tags into a toolbox
toy box or container so to speak right
and we already already mentioned that
hey you can bypass your webmaster so
you're probably thinking well if i'm
if you're not familiar with tag manager
how can i bypass my webmaster well
first of all it's a free tool and it's a
google tool hence the name google tag
manager
and it helps you really that's the main
point is deploy and track tags on your
website
by passing your webmaster so that's tag
manager
and so examples of tags that can be
deployed
via google tag manager are numerous
these are just
some examples like google analytics
facebook pixel tracking or
google ads there's no limit
into the number of texts you can track
in tag manager
there is no limit you can add any number
of
tracking tags and tag manager okay so
some of the benefits
well again i we just listed two you can
put any tag
into tag manager and track that onto
your website and we know you can bypass
your web developer
or webmaster and what it also does is it
also allows you to
test and deploy your javascript codes
quicker so remember these javascript
codes or snippets of codes
are just there to track certain things
on your website
whether that be a page view or somebody
clicking on a play button or
tracking somebody who converts or even
just goes to your website
so the biggest benefit is you can take
that snippet of code let's just say
facebook let's just say you're doing
facebook marketing
and you want to put that facebook pixel
on your website
so that you could track people who come
from facebook and convert
well you don't need to put that facebook
pixel on your website you can go right
to tag manager
and you can put that snippet of code
right in tag manager
really quickly and the other benefit
here
is all tags are managed in one place and
that's that to me is really a good
benefit because
when you start adding tags on your
website and you have some tags in tag
manager it just gets
very confusing so ideally all the
tracking codes you have on your website
needs to be in tag manager
think about that all the tracking so if
you're doing bing or you're doing
facebook or you're doing twitter or
you're doing linkedin and you're doing
google you're doing all this type of
marketing on all these different
platforms you're gonna have tracking
code for all these different platforms
and instead of putting on that code on
your website
return gonna slow down the slow time of
your web page and website you wanna put
them all in tag manager so they can be
organized
and you know exactly what you're trying
to track and the other great benefit of
tag manager is there's a
versioning control so let's just say you
have added tags to your website
via gtm for the last six months well and
let's just say you add another tag
yesterday if you added that tag
yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version
it's that simple so you have versioning
and that's that's a good thing when you
have versioning you can control
what gets published and if something
doesn't work after it gets published
then you can roll back to a previous
version so
it's a a piece of mind so to speak just
because you've added code to your site
there's no guarantee it's going to work
and so you can always control what
version
you're dealing with in tag manager and
we'll talk a little bit more about that
so the biggest benefit here to me with
tag manager
is you have event tracking and so we
talked about some of the things you
could track on your website
from videos from play buttons to
somebody clicking on the stop on the
video or pausing it
all the way to somebody again chatting
or let's just say somebody clicking on
that purchase button on your website
okay and you want to track all these
different things these different
interactivities and buttons well event
tracking
is what you're going to use to track all
those buttons and to me this
is the biggest benefit of tag manager
and i'll show you some examples as we go
along
and if we didn't mention it already i'll
mention it again it is free
tag manager is free there's no limit so
once you have tag manager going
you can add as many tracking codes as
you want there's no limit on the number
of
tracking codes you can add to tag
manager okay so it's free
and you can use it to its fullest
advantage okay so it's also high
security meaning
that it has different levels of
permissions okay
so you can have uh somebody just go in
and look
at the different tags and tracking code
you have in gtm
or you can have somebody who is very
familiar with tag manager and can go in
and add the tracking code to tag manager
and then
publish that tracking code when it gets
added so those are all the benefits
let's talk about how it works now
specifically how does tag manager work
because you're like rob okay again a lot
of jargon
you know you you got tags and javascript
and
versioning and publishing and all this
other stuff well
i know i'm throwing a lot at you at once
but just bear with me here okay so let's
start talking about
how it actually works so you have a
website
okay whatever that domain is you have a
website and there's chances are on your
website
you have some form of interactivity
whether that be a video
whether that be a blog whether it be a
form submission you have a website with
some interactivity
and let's just say you're even thinking
about getting ready to launch some type
of campaign on maybe
google or facebook and you want to drive
traffic to your website fair enough
you're joining the millions of other
websites that are out there that have
interactivity that also drive traffic to
the website
so income's google tag manager and so
tag manager is important because again
we know we want to track
people coming from that facebook
campaign or that google campaign and
interacting with our site
so if you are running facebook and you
are running google analytics well
guess what you want to put that tracking
code
in tag manager so google analytics being
a google product
works very nicely with tag manager
facebook has its own tracking code
but you still want to be able to track
people who come from the facebook
campaign to your website
so you're gonna get that tracking code
from facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source
through tag manager so think about that
if i add facebook tracking code
to tag manager or let's just say a
google analytics tracking code to tag
manager
tag manager is the one that's pushing
out
and doing all the heavy lifting they're
the ones that are controlling
what code gets fired and what code
doesn't so if you're putting the code in
tag manager tag manager is controlling
the code think about it that way and
let's show you an example of what that
looks like
so here i am i'm in tag manager i just
went to tag manager.google.com
and here i could see a list of tags so
in our conversation we're talking about
tracking facebook and we're talking
about tracking google analytics well
google analytics is easy because it's a
google product so
here if i look at all the different
tracking code i have on my website
through tag manager
let's just take a look at google
analytics so if you're going to use tag
manager
you might as well put the google
analytics code in here so here i can see
i have google analytics as a tag
in tag manager now for facebook if i'm
running a facebook campaign
well i can take that pixel tracking and
put it in gtm as well
and here i could see facebook pixel that
is that code is added to
gtm i just basically took what facebook
gave me
and put it into google tag manager so
you can see
i can add facebook and google analytics
and again
i can't stress it enough any tracking
code
from any platform i can add to google
tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive
into how tag manager works so i just
showed you an example of how you could
take
facebook and google analytics code and
put it into tag manager
but if you're not familiar with tag
manager then how do i do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so
when you have a tag manager account you
have a container remember
i mentioned toy box earlier you have a
bunch of toys if they're
they're code and you're tracking
different bits of code from different
platforms like facebook think of those
as toys and you have a toy box
okay well that's what this code is and
that's what a container is
the code is the code and that's going to
go into the toy box or container
and so the way tag manager works is you
have tags
triggers and variables so if i take my
facebook tracking code
and put it into a container i need to
set up a tag and a trigger okay so let's
take a look at
what that is so first if i go back to
tag manager
i'm going to have an account and if i
have an account i'm going to have a
container
so here i'm just going to click on an
account with a container and a container
is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code
to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know
this is the website we're adding all
this code to
so you have tags triggers and variables
that's the structure of tag manager so
tags are just what it says tags what are
we trying to quote unquote tag
well if it's google analytics that's
easy here i can see
i've google analytics added so if i
click on google analytics here's my tag
and if i take a little bit of a deeper
dive there since
google analytics is a google product it
integrates already with tag managers
it's pretty easy
i can just choose google analytics then
i'm going to check
page view and that's my tag now
every tag needs a trigger okay so
i need to tell tag manager how or when
to fire the google analytics tracking
code so in this case
i'm going to tell tag manager to fire on
all pages so if i get somebody a visitor
to my website
analytics is firing on all pages so
whatever page that visitor lands on
google analytics is going to fire so
that's really what it comes down to
is i have a tag and i need to tell tag
manager
when to trigger that tag that's really
what the structure of tag manager is
it's tags triggers and variables and
variables what we're going to talk about
here
in a couple minutes but you have a piece
of code you're going to go ahead and put
that
into tag manager you're going to tag it
and then you're going to fire that
trigger
so let's take a look at another example
here if i go back
here you can see facebook well here's my
facebook pixel
okay that's my tag so when is it gonna
fire well it's gonna fire on a specific
domain or subdomain that's basically
what we're doing we're trying to tell
gtm when
to fire that particular tag so
those are the three main components a
tag okay
which is going to contain the javascript
code
that you get from say facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger
and then you have variables and so
variables
are basically just additional
information
that tag manager may need for your tag
and trigger to work so that's what a
variable is it's there
to get the tag and trigger to fire so
variables are divided into
built-in and user-defined variables so
common used variables include
say page path or page url or hostname
or click class again they're there
and these examples i just gave you are
there to
get your tag and trigger to work think
about it that way they're just
that's a component and if i go into tag
manager here
and here on the left side i can see
variables
so remember i have built in and user
defined
so built in means that tag manager
already built these for me
so in case i need to get my trigger
to work with my tag i can use a variable
so those are built in and then i have
user to find so these are
what i define these are what i created
and again the variables are there to get
the tag and trigger to work okay so
that's the job of the variable
the job of the tag is to host that
javascript code okay in the case of
facebook or
analytics that's where we're putting our
code so here if i click on adwords
remarketing
again it's a google product so i don't
really need to even deal with code
i'm just going to select google adwords
remarketing okay so you can see
gtm integrates nicely with some of the
other
google products but let's just say you
have
a facebook pixel tracking code you're
gonna choose custom
and you're gonna put the code here so
that's part of the tag and then the
trigger again is there to get the tag to
fire so you're telling gtm when to fire
the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure
that that trigger and that tag work
together
so that's how all three kind of work
together
you need the tag to put the code you
need the trigger to tell gtm when to
fire the tag in code
and the variables there to help you
define
when that tag and trigger should work or
how it should work
so again review tags are they're just
small codes of javascript or tracking
pixels on your website and so tags are
allowed to manage events like scroll
track and remarketing
clicks downloads files play buttons you
name it
and even clicks on external links for
example let's just say you have a click
uh or a facebook uh icon on your site
and when somebody clicks on it they go
to facebook you want to maybe track that
you're going to create a tag okay the
trigger is there because
you need to tell gtm when to fire that
tag
so it's a certain condition whether it's
you know fire the tag if the url
equals facebook.com or some other
condition so the tag
cannot be created until the creation of
the corresponding trigger so tags and
triggers go together
you can't just create a tag and not have
a trigger otherwise your tag will never
fire and then the variable is there
again
it stores the information when defining
a trigger or transferring data to tag so
a variable has a variety of data okay so
you
pick and choose the variable you want to
use with that trigger
okay so you're making sure that by
defining a variable you're making sure
that you're telling gtm how that trigger
should be fired so let's take a look at
another example here of how all three
play together
if i'm in this account i'm in this
container
if i look down here i could see google
optimize
that's another google product so what
i'm doing here
is i just chose google optimize as my
tag it's
already integrated so what does that
mean i don't even need to
deal with any code i'm just going to
select optimize
well we have the tag google optimize but
we need to tell
gtm how to fire that and so here we're
going to
tell gtm to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages
so if i want to look at something
specific again facebook
here's my tag here's my code what's my
trigger
well my trigger is it's going fire on
specific pages
how do i know that well if i look at the
trigger
here i could see the trigger is a page
view
but i'm telling it to fire on this
particular host name
so the tag and trigger go hand in hand
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so
you're going to go to tag
manager.google.com
or you can do a search for google tag
manager and you're going to create your
account
and then when you create your account
what's going to happen is
you're going to set up a container
and when you set up a container you have
choices
so you could set it up for your website
for
an app on ios or maybe android
or you can even set it up for amp etc an
accelerated mobile page
so most people by default are probably
going to set up tag manager for their
website
and so when you do that when you
actually select website
what's going to happen is you're going
to get some google tag manager code in
return
and so the whole idea here is
you're going to do a swap what you're
doing is basically you're saying okay
google
i'm going to take this google tag
manager code and i'm going to put it on
my website i'm going to put it on
every page in my website so notice tag
manager
has two scripts one goes in the head
as high as possible the other goes into
the body tag
as high as possible and so what you're
doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and
in return every code you deal with
whether that be facebook or analytics or
optimize or remarketing or whatever it
is
is going to go in gtm okay it's going to
go into the container you created
so you need the tag manager code on your
website
in order for tag manager to work okay so
when you add this code to your website
then you're free to start adding all
sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website
then none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work
so that's the idea behind the container
and then one thing i wanted to mention
on the account
is it's a google account so when you
create your account
then make sure it's the same account you
use with say google analytics or some
other google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same
email address when you set up your
account so that it integrates nicely
across
all the different platforms meaning you
can go from say google analytics right
to google tag manager
in one browser without having to log out
or log in okay so when you create the
account you're gonna create your
container
if you choose web then you're going to
be asked to place
code on your website and when you place
that code on your website
then you are free to start using tag
manager and that means you're free to
start adding tags
so if you want to know more information
about installing
google tag manager then what i would
recommend is visit the quick start guide
website of gtm so again if you're
curious as to where that code is located
in google tag manager well when you
create
an account and you create a container
that container is going to have a
specific
id so if i click on that specific id
here's where i can get my code okay so
again when i'm logged in
to tag manager i'm going to click on
workspace but in the
top navigation i'm going to see my
unique gtm id
if i click on that that's where my code
is going to be located
and so again your code needs to go in
the header and there's another script
that needs to go in the body
and if you're not sure how to add the
code to your website
well you can always click on the quick
start guide here okay
and that'll take you to a quick start
guide
page a reference page related to google
tag manager
so let's talk about creating a tag
so once you get tag manager installed
i'm sure you're excited to get going
and create that first tag so let's talk
about
how to create a tag in tag manager
so when you're in tag manager all you
need to do
is basically you're looking at all your
tags if you click on tag in the left
side navigation you'll see all your tags
and there's a new button there so you
just click new
and so basically what you're gonna do is
you're going to create your first tag
and so what i would recommend
once you get tag manager installed on
your website
i would recommend setting the first tag
up as google analytics
so that will get you going with tracking
page views on your website when some
when somebody visits your website okay
so ideally that's what you want to do
you want to get google analytics
as your first tag and tag manager so
what i'm going to do
is because analytics is a google product
it's already
integrated nicely with tag manager so
i'm just going to click on
google analytics it's going to be a page
for you that's what i'm tracking
and now i have to set up a variable and
so
what it's going to do it's going to ask
me to sort of
select a variable and so what you're
going to do is you're going to select
new variable
and what you're going to do is you're
actually going to go and add your
tracking id here
that's going to be your variable so
where do i get my tracking id
and analytics well if i'm in analytics
i'm going to go to admin
and then under property settings i'm
gonna see my tracking id
and all you need to do then is go to tag
manager
and paste copy first you gotta copy over
that tracking id
then you're gonna go to tag manager and
paste it and then that's gonna create
a variable for you and then when you
create that variable you're gonna see it
in the drop down here
so i've already created it and basically
that's your tag with a variable then
what are you gonna do
you're gonna set up a trigger so see i
have some triggers already set
up you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you
and that's going to be all pages so
ideally what you want to do
is you want to select all pages in order
for
analytics to fire on all pages so that's
what we're doing we're setting up a
trigger
we're basically telling tag manager hey
if i get a visitor to any page on my
website
then i want you to fire google analytics
so that's basically in summary
how to set up your first tag and my
recommendation is your first tag should
be google analytics and when you set up
analytics
you're going to have to set up a
variable for the tracking id
and so you get the tracking id again
from admin
property settings copy and paste that
tracking id
over save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be
included in with the tag then your
trigger is going to be all pages
and there you go you have your first tag
you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do
and once you've added that tag once
you've added that trigger
then the only thing you need to do now
is basically
publish the tag and so anytime you save
a tag you're going to go ahead
and submit it so that way it gets
published
so again what you're going to do is
let's take a step back here
you're going to choose new tag you're
going to choose
analytics from the drop down menu you're
going to choose page view
then basically you're going to add your
tracking id
so you can set up the variable and then
basically that's what you need to do
okay you're going to add that tracking
id and then voila
that's your tag with a variable and then
once you've done that
then you're going to click submit so
when you click submit
you're basically saying hey i want this
tag to go live now
this tag and trigger and once you've
done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
google analytics
so the great thing here is you have
something called google tag
assistant and that's an extension that
works with chrome
and so when you've actually added tag
manager to your site
or you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm
if those tags are firing properly so
let's take a look at
how google tag assistant works okay so
if you just do a
search for google tag assistant you're
gonna see here
that it's basically just an extension
that works in chrome and
unfortunately it only works in chrome
browser it doesn't work in any other
browser
so go ahead and install that extension
into chrome and when you do that you're
going to see this nice
icon here in your browser and now if you
go to any website
and i click on google tag assistant and
i click on enable
okay so basically i'm loading google tag
assistant
and now once i refresh the page i can
see that
this particular site has google tag
manager installed
and not only does it have tag manager
installed i can see that
it's also has google analytics running i
have also google optimize running
and i have google ads remarketing tag
running in
tag manager so that's what tag assistant
does it allows you to see
if one tag manager is on the site
and if it is great what other tags are
firing
on this particular site so tag
assistant's telling me i have
these particular tags firing on that
site and they're firing within tag
manager
so tag assistant is a great way to
confirm
if one tag manager is on the site and
two what other tags are firing
on the site now another way you could
confirm if
tag manager is firing on the site is you
can go into preview mode
so even before you submit and publish
your tag and trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
i click preview in tag manager
so basically that's going to put me in
preview mode and so what does that mean
well that means that
now i'm free to go to my website and see
if those tags are firing and so let's
take a look at what that looks like so
if i go to the website and just click
refresh then what's going to happen
is tag manager is going to load in
preview mode
just as you see here okay so that's
going to take a second couple seconds to
load up
and now what can i see in preview mode i
could see
that i have gtm firing but i also have
some other text firing on this page
remarketing
i have google analytics i have google
optimize
i have some other tags firing as well
and so the preview mode shows me what
tags are firing on any given page and i
can also see what tags did not fire
okay so here i have a number of tags
already in gtm but they didn't fire on
this particular page
so let's just say i clicked on the
donate now button i'm still in preview
mode
so i'm gonna be able to see what tags
fired
now i could see i have a couple of tags
that have fired on this particular page
and then i can see what tags did not
fire on this page okay
so that's the preview mode you can use
the preview mode
before you even submit a tag and trigger
to see if it fires and that's
the great benefit of tag manager so if
you're not sure if something's going to
fire or not
then you can always go into preview mode
um and if you are sure it's going to
fire
then you can go ahead and submit it so
you can leave preview mode and just go
ahead and submit that particular tag and
trigger
so here i'm going to leave preview mode
and now
once i'm done and i'm sure the tag is
going to fire
and go ahead and submit all my changes
that i've worked on in terms of setting
up tags and triggers so that's really
gtm in a nutshell so i have
my tags okay my tags are just snippets
of code that i'm going to put in whether
that be facebook or vet tracking
or any other google product like
optimize or page view
then i have my triggers my triggers are
there to tell
gtm when to fire that tag and the
variables are there
to help those tags and triggers work
together so remember that
particular variable we set up for google
analytics
okay so here it is right here because we
want to tell
gtm what property to specifically fire
in google analytics so that's why we set
up that variable but there are all sorts
of variables google
tag manager has built in or variables
already created for you
or you can specifically define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers
work together so when you set up a tag
you set up a trigger you use a variable
you can always go into preview mode
preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires
then voila you can go ahead and
click submit and that will publish the
tag and trigger
and you're good to go that's pretty much
how tag manager works
and again i can't stress that there is
an
unlimited number of tags you can add
to tag manager there's no limit so
you got everything from anything from
google to non-google
to event tracking okay to facebook to
anything that you want to track
you want to be able to put into tag
manager and again
there's versioning that's one of the
great benefits of tag manager so if i
want to go back to an
older version i can simply do that so
here you can see i'm on version 32.
that's how tag manager works and
i can't stress that you know tag manager
is there to help you track interactivity
on the site because if you have a site
that's interactive that has a video
that has a download button let's just
say
you know you have all sorts of
newsletter sign ups facebook
youtube buttons on your website just
like this website does
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on that particular
button
well you're going to need tag manager
and when you have tag manager you're
gonna be able to track
all of these button clicks and
interactivity on your website without
tag manager
it's gonna be hard to do that so that's
an introduction to tag manager
today we're to talk about how to rank
number one
on google so let's get started and
um let's go with the scenario that
you have a friend named sam and he has a
website
where he sells shoes but sam doesn't
understand
why his website's not ranking number one
on google
and so typically ranked number one on
google
there are some factors involved and
those are factors that are going to help
sam get his website ranked number one on
google so he can sell his shoes
get traffic and convert that traffic to
conversions
so there are factors involved and so
what are those
factors well it always starts with
keyword research so in order to rank
for a website where you sell shoes or
you sell products other products like
clothing or
food or your automobile
website you know you're a mechanic it
doesn't matter
whether you're selling to customers or
selling to other businesses you
have to start with the keyword research
and so we're going to go into
really explicit detail on how to
conduct a proper keyword research and
then the second factor involved
is high quality content so in order to
rank
high on google search you need to have
high quality content so we're going to
go over what's involved with creating
high quality content then we're going to
take that content we're going to
optimize it using on
page elements and website level factors
so we're going to take into account
what's involved with your website and
what's involved with specific pages on
your website
in order to rank number one on google
then we're going to get into the
off site engagement so when it comes to
ranking on google
you need to optimize your website and
you need to do
some elements off your website you need
to be
engaging off your website meaning on
other websites
and so we're going to talk about what's
involved with offsite engagement
so seo being a major channel for most
companies and websites where the
opportunity to drive a lot of traffic is
there
but you have to earn that reward the
reward is a lot of traffic
but you have to earn the reward there's
a lot of work involved and so
ideally what we want to do is follow
what we call the 80 20
rule when it comes to search engine
optimization
and ranking on google and what do we
mean by the 80 20 rule
well 80 20 means we're investing
20 of our effort and 80 percent of the
results are obtained
so we want to invest 20 and get back 80.
that's basically what we mean by 80
20. so for example if 20 of our targeted
keywords
bring in 80 of the traffic then that's
following the 80 20 rule
or 20 of our landing pages drive 80
percent of the overall traffic
that's following the 80 20 rule or 20 of
our backlinks past
80 percent of our link juice that's the
80 20 rule
meaning these targeted keywords these
targeted landing pages these
trying to target backlinks using
off-site
engagement we want to put in 20 of our
effort
on those keywords landing pages and
backlinks in return
for 80 of the results so
without further ado let's get started
with the keyword research
let's talk about that keyword research
for
a website with shoes and it doesn't
really matter
what particular product you have if you
need to rank number one on google
it all starts with the keywords as i
mentioned before
and so in this example if you have a
website
where you sell shoes for kids you're
going to want to be found for certain
keywords so
the obvious keyword here would be shoes
for kids
well every keyword that you target
has search volume associated with it so
that means when we talk about search
volume
we're talking about how many people on
average
type in that keyword or related keyword
on google.com or google search and
there's always an average number of
searches associated with every keyword
and we call that search volume
how much search volume so obviously if
we're going to target a keyword
we want to have as much volume as
possible however
there's always going to be competition
for those keywords meaning there's
always going to be other websites who
want to rank
number one on google for the same
keywords and we call that competition or
difficulty
so for every keyword you're going to
have volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty
and the difficulty ranges as well
depending on the tool you use
and we'll get into that in a minute but
search volume
is how much on average people are typing
in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword
and the difficulty is measured in terms
of
how many other websites are trying to
rank for the same keyword
and so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business
so if we're selling shoes for kids and
shoes for kids
is highly relevant has high volume and
low competition
then that's a key word we want to target
so we always want to focus in on those
three areas
so there's always a trade-off with
keywords so shoes for kids might have
high volume but also
might have high competition or
difficulty
if we look for another keyword that's
just as relevant for example shoes for
children
it may still have high search volume but
the competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may
be a better keyword for us to target
instead of something
highly competitive like shoes for kids
we can focus on another relevant keyword
like shoes for children
with just as much volume and lower
competition
and the reason why we want lower
competition is because
we want to be able to rank for that
keyword so the higher the competition
the harder it is for us to rank number
one on google
for that keyword and so the whole idea
beyond keyword research is
analyzing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant
we want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for
and we want to use third party tools to
choose keywords
to identify which keywords have low
competition
and what keywords have high search
volume so
one thing to take into consideration
when you're doing keyword research
is that the longer the keyword phrase
or in other words long tail keywords or
keywords with three keywords in the
phrase or more
you're going to always have less
competition but there's always a
trade-off
with long tail keywords meaning the
longer the keyword phrase
there's going to be less volume but the
trade-off is less competition and so
what we want to do
is we want to brainstorm some ideas and
find those relevant keywords so let's
look at an example here
so if we go to google ads
so google ads has a tool called keyword
planner
and let's just say i have a a website
where i'm
selling dried figs and if i'm selling
dried figs i want people to buy these
dried figs however
in order to attract them i want to be
able to show them that hey we have a
bunch of recipes and if i show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs
maybe you'll buy these dried figs to use
in these recipes
and so we're going to look for keywords
related to bread recipes
because if we can optimize for our
recipes page for bread
then that will attract an audience who
wants to make bread
and use dried figs with those bread
recipes so that's the example i'm going
to give here
and so if i look at the keyword planner
in google ads if i just type in bread
recipes
what google is going to do is they're
going to give me
an average monthly search volume so i
can see the average
monthly search volume here is sixty
thousand five hundred
and so in order to do keyword research
what i would recommend
is keep a spreadsheet and so the idea
behind the spreadsheet
is to document the volume and the
competition you're getting for certain
keywords so if i go into a spreadsheet
here my theme of keywords is bread
recipes
my keyword is bread recipes and my
volume therefore is going to be
60 500. however if i go back
into google's keyword planner google's
telling me the competition is low
so that's great i want high volume i
want low competition
but how low is low so we want to be
careful
so if we're going to put in numbers into
a spreadsheet we want to figure out what
that competition really is
for the keyword bread recipes so if i go
to google and just type in bread recipes
i'm going to be able to see 771
billion results for the keyword bread
recipes
now is 771 billion
are real competition maybe maybe not
what we want to do
is put in a syntax and we want to put in
the syntax
all in title and then colon space and
then our keyword and the reason why we
do that
in search is because we want to be able
to identify the true
competitive number or the true number of
websites
who are trying to rank for bread recipes
and if we put in the syntax
all entitled colon and then our keyword
bread recipes
we'll be able to see that there are 998
000 results that's a lot lower than 771
billion
so that means that 998
000 sites or listings have the keyword
bread recipes
in the title tag and the title tag is
what shows up in the search engine
results
and so if i look down and scroll down
here i can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags
so title tag is an important element to
rank number one on google and we'll talk
about that
in a few minutes but if we understand
that there are 998
000 results with bread recipes in the
title tag
then this tells us that those are the
websites who are trying to
rank number one on google for that
keyword and therefore
those are the websites we need to jump
over in order for our website
to rank number one on google and so
therefore i'm going to put in 998
000 in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number
and so now i could see for the keyword
bread recipes
i have 60 500 and if my competition is
998
000 then my kei or
keyboard effectiveness index or in other
words the ratio
of volume to competition is six percent
so that's nothing more
than volume divided by competition so
that tells me
that my kei or my ratio between
volume competition is six percent so
remember we want
more volume than we want competition so
anytime you do a keyword research
you're going to find a number of
different relevant keywords so if i go
back
into google's keyword planner if i typed
in bread recipes you could see that
google is going to give me a number of
different
keywords related to bread recipes let's
just say i have another keyword
that i want to think about optimizing
for being
ranked on google for and that's banana
bread recipe
very similar keyword as bread recipes
except it's a little
longer tail now if i type in banana
bread recipe
in google's keyword planner now i can
see the average monthly search volume
has actually gone up
it's 368 000. i can also see the
competition is low
so those are good signs so now i can see
368 000 i'm going to go ahead and put
that in my spreadsheet
now i'm going to go into google i'm
going to put in my syntax all in title
i'm going to put in banana bread recipe
i'm going to hit enter
and now i can see i have 233
000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe
in the title tag so if i look at the
title tags i can see banana bread recipe
banana bread recipe
banana bread recipe on all the listings
in the google search results so that
tells me i have 233
000 results that i have to jump over in
order to rank number one on google
so i'm going to put 233 000 in
my spreadsheet now i can see my kei
or my volume to competition ratio is 157
158 and so to me that's a lot
better number to work with or in other
words that's a
lot better keyword because it's just as
relevant
and it has a higher ratio of volume to
competition
so therefore banana bread recipe is
going to be
a better keyword to optimize for
in order to rank number one on google so
that's the whole idea behind keyword
research
you want to brainstorm ideas there are
plenty of tools out there
so the tool i recommend is google ads
keyword planner
google is going to give you how much
search volume
they're going to tell you the
competition but then you're going to go
into google search you're going to use
the syntax
all in title to get a more accurate read
on the actual
competitive number and so to find out
how keywords that your competitors are
ranking for
you can use those keyword tools that i
mentioned another
tool that i use is miles so moz if you
go to moz.com
they have a tool called keyword explorer
so if we just type in the keyword
for example bread recipes it's going to
be able to tell us
how much volume and the difficulty so
you can use other tools at your disposal
figure out
the volume and the difficulty there are
plenty of tools out there
but the one thing i would just make sure
is you use everything at your disposal
so you can use
social media to find the most shared
article for a particular topic or
keyword like bread recipes
you could check other platforms that
have a lot of shared content
like reading and quora where you can ask
people about certain topics
using keywords to figure out how much
competition or volume there might be
you could stay up to date on industry
news to get an idea
of what types of keywords are trending
but when it comes to
keywords and keyword research remember
for every web page we want to be able to
pick two keywords we want a primary
and secondary keyword so when we do
keyword research
and we enter all our keywords into our
spreadsheet
we want to be able to have a number of
different keywords
in this case we're focusing on the theme
bread recipes
we want to have different keywords
because we want to be able to choose a
primary keyword
and a secondary keyword because we want
to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket maybe we
won't want to put all our emphasis just
on
one keyword to rank for we want multiple
keywords to try and rank for
so the primary key work and to find the
nature of our business
the secondary keyword could be just
highly relevant to our keyword
at the end of the day we want to choose
multiple keywords
to try and rank on google for that page
so for example we have a blog and we're
using ice cream
recipes and we're blogging about ice
cream recipes we can have a primary
keyword
that is about ice cream recipes or
homemade ice cream recipes we're going
to always want to find out what the
volume and the
competition is our secondary keyword
could be built around other similar
keywords like
low-fat ice cream recipes or fat-free
ice cream recipes
or low-fat homemade ice cream recipes
those are complementary keywords
just like our bread recipes and banana
bread recipe
so one thing we want to do when we do
keyword
research is we want to be able to target
one keyword per content when you can
target many we want to be able to target
multiple keywords not necessarily target
one keyword
and so we want to be able to cluster
keywords
so we don't want to target just one we
want to target
multiple keywords per page and when we
talk about clustering if we go back to
our keyword research what we're doing is
we're clustering a bunch of keywords
under the theme bread recipes and so
by looking at the volume looking at the
competition looking at the kei we can
choose
different keywords for our page and
that's what we mean by clustering we
want to cluster keywords
into a content theme so why target only
one keyword per content when we can
target many
because we don't want to put all our
eggs in one basket we don't want to
target just one keyword we want to
target many
and so that means clustering your
keywords into a theme
and choosing multiple keywords for that
particular page
and when we do that we have a better
opportunity to
rank high on google search and the whole
idea behind ranking high on google
search
is we can get the volume so if we know
we're ranked number one
on google search for bread recipes or
banana bread recipe
we know we stand a chance of getting a
majority of the volume associated with
that keyword
and if we can get the volume and get the
traffic
then we can get the conversions so let's
move on to
high quality content and talk about the
impact
content has on your ability to
get your website ranked number one on
google
so let's just say you have content on
your website
and the content is ranking on you know
page four of google
and it's that blog with ice cream
recipes
and if it's just content for the sake of
content is not really informative
then it's not necessarily gonna get good
engagement
in the eyes of google you know they want
to rank content that's very informative
it's very fresh
it's exciting to read it's interesting
it's going to have good engagement
so if it's a recipe or an article about
any topic if it's the content is just
not informative
then you're not going to get good
engagement and when you don't get good
engagement if people
don't stay on the site to engage in the
content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce
then the content is just going to
continue to fall down the rankings
and we want to prevent that we want to
move up the rankings we want to be
number one on google we don't
necessarily
want to fall in the rankings for our
content so content is a key
driver in being able to rank number one
on google
so if the content is on page nine what
can we do well we want to be able to
you know take that content and do
something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media
and to me social media is a good
platform to share your content because
on social media platforms like facebook
for example
you're building a community on that
platform that community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe
especially in the summer time and you're
engaging with your community on that
platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform
is going to increase engagement
increased engagement
will send social signals to the search
engine that says hey
this content is good quality likewise
for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics
and those engagement metrics pass
signals
is it good is it not good do we like
this content are we giving it a thumbs
up
are we going to want to follow it are we
going to want to share it and so
if you share content that you feel is
engaging on
social platforms then it's going to be
engaging
and it's likely going to cause an
increase in engagement
for example a decrease in bounces and
once you share that quality content then
the likelihood of it moving
up the rankings even as far as number
one on google is going to be greater
so you always want to start out writing
good
quality content so let's talk about good
quality content
because google does take content
seriously they do
take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content
is an important factor so how to create
good content that's always the question
so let's talk about some best practices
here
remember in the last segment we talked
about keyword research so we want to
perform
good keyword research why because we
want to choose keywords
remember we're choosing multiple
keywords per page
one keyword could be related to our
brand
one keyword could be related to the
content but another keyword could be
related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes
maybe somebody's looking to type in a
keyword that says
how do i make you know a bread or how do
i make a specific type of bread or how
do i make banana bread
or what's the best recipe for banana
bread they're
question related and we want to be able
to answer those questions so that's
where
choosing those right keywords that's
going to respond to a user's intent
so starts with choosing the right
keywords so
remember we talked about a number of
different tools when we talked about
keyword research so
there's a research tool that you can use
called
phrase.io and that will help you do
quick research
on you know keywords and trends and
whatnot so
if you know about a research tool that
you use
for keyword research then drop us a
comment below i'd be interested in
getting your comments
about keyword research and what research
tools are out there
so if you know something better than
phrase.io drop a comment below
and we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so
keyword research is key but creating
content that fulfills users requirements
so
answering those questions it's a recipe
we want to answer that question
if it's directions we want to answer
that question if they don't know how to
do something we want to answer that
question that's the whole idea behind
content
content is not just to fill a page it's
to really fulfill
users requirements that's when you get
good engagement
so if somebody's typing in something on
google and they're looking for an answer
your content should answer that question
but we also want to make the content
readable
so in other words you know write for
your audience
don't impress anybody with very high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use jargon
don't use a street language for example
use everyday common language that's just
easily
digestible when your audience is reading
and then we want to keep that
content organized and so when we mean
organized we want to use
headers and subheaders you know break
your content into paragraphs
keep the flow organized if we can keep
the flow organized
then it's going to be easier for
somebody to read and then
it's okay to add resources especially
resources from credible sites so if you
can incorporate those resources in there
then it's just going to add the
credibility to your content let the
audience know that hey
i've done my research on this topic and
this is what this person has to say
about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content
so these are all tips to remember when
creating content
and then the one important tip here is
we want to use white hat techniques and
when we say white hat techniques that
means
you know if we've chosen keywords that
are going to answer somebody's question
we don't want to
stuff those keywords into the content we
want the content to be naturally written
so when we say opt for white hat
techniques that's what we mean
write the content naturally keep it
organized
keep it readable include third-party
sources
and make sure it answers a question so
there are different types of content
so there's content where you just write
words to install
text based you could also use an
infographic an infographic
is simply just a graphic that visualizes
exactly what you're trying to explain
for example
if we want to write an article about
how to write good engaging content we
don't necessarily have to write all that
out as a text we can create an
infographic
so for example here's an infographic on
20 effective ways to basically not
bore your readers but write engaging
content so you could see this is an
infographic
it's all graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be
easier to understand because they're
visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because
there's generally no jargon it's usually
images that are portraying the point
of what you're trying to get across and
so it tends to break it up the monotony
of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic
has 20 different steps or rules and they
lay those out
all here in this infographic and the
great thing i like about infographics is
you could you could share them on social
media
you can re-engage them as a post you
could save them on really any social
platform
so infographics tend to tell a better
story
and versus say just writing text you can
use video and images
so you don't necessarily have to lay it
all out in an infographic
you can certainly insert a video or an
image
into your content especially if it's a
blog post if it's a blog post
then sometimes video and images on its
own
tell the story you don't necessarily
need
text to go ahead and tell your story
a video or an image as they say tells a
thousand words
and so images and videos are great to
use in a blog post
so using different forms of content you
know you always want to review your
content
when a user dwells on your web page for
a longer time
google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorably
so if you're using infographics videos
and images
then the chances of somebody being more
engaged are going to increase
versus just text that's not well
organized
and written out in a way that somebody
doesn't necessarily understand
so be creative in the types of content
you use
so longer engaging content tends to
bode well with search engines so
this is according to hubspot so the more
word count you use the more words you
use the chances of you ranking higher
are going to be better just take into
account
best practices you want to maybe break
up the content
with an image organize it make it
engaging use headers
so it's not necessarily just words it's
the words and how those words are
written
how they're structured the types of
keywords you're using
how you're engaging with your audience
there's a lot of factors again
those best practices we just went over
but the key is you know if you have
longer more engaging content then it's
going to bode better for you
on search engines so a couple of steps
to create
high quality content so you want to
begin with a comprehensive
introduction so always introduce your
content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keywords so
if you're choosing keywords in your
keyword research think about
answering that question if somebody's
typing in bread recipes maybe they're
looking for banana bread recipes
how to make the best banana bread or how
to make banana bread using dried figs
we want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally
you want to create a title that's worthy
that's click worthy so remember
if you're in google search and you're
doing search for
something simple like bread recipes we
want to
make something that's going to be you
know engaging for somebody to click on
like easy perfect yeast bread or easy
crusty french bread or something that's
going to be engaging
you know the best bread recipes or how
to make the best homemade bread
you know something that's going to draw
somebody's attention
to the title of that blog post so we
want to include
lsi keywords so what i mean by lsi
keywords in your content
we mean you know long tail keywords make
it natural
headings and subheadings should consist
of keywords and variants so
if you're writing headers and subheaders
include the keyword in there and that
way the the content
always stays relevant to the audience
okay shorten your sentences and
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easy
for the end user to read and we
want to always put internal links
on our blog post why because if we have
internal links then
if we have a link from one blog post to
another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website
we want to make sure that it's relevant
content that way
somebody's reading something and you
have an internal link
let's just say from a bread recipes page
to
a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click
on that link and go to the banana bread
recipes page so it's keeping somebody
engaged on your website so
putting in internal linking will help
keep the end user engaged because
you're offering up links that's relevant
to the content you always want to break
up that content with images
okay we want to use alt tags meaning we
want to
pen the image with text so that way the
image doesn't load
then at least the alt text will load so
we can incorporate call out boxes
and more importantly we want to update
our content regularly so we always want
to
get the best recipe out there if it's
banana bread
or different ways to create banana bread
or always just
coming up with ways to update the
content so we want to keep our content
our blog post
fresh and then we want to include a cta
call to action if we include a call to
action
then that's going to keep somebody
engaged and have
them act on your content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three month old post on
buzzfeed
and it's 21 pictures that restore your
faith in humanity so it has a lot of
likes a lot of tweaks
and that means it's engaged people are
engaged when reading that
and so if we go and look at it as an
example we could see it on a buzzfeed
here
21 pictures that will restore your faith
in humanity so
this was written back in 2012 again a
lot
of engagement but if we look at it
we can see immediately that it's taking
into account
third-party sources it's got some
content it's got images it's being
broken up by images
we could see there's call to actions on
there in the form of social so people
can go ahead
and go ahead and share it if they like
it
okay it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because
listen you know it's engaging content
it's probably answering somebody's
question about humanity
and we could see clearly that look you
know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content
so not just video not just images but
text as well
and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different
types of content available so this is a
good post
in that regard so content's updated
regularly
it's engaging and it includes sources
from high authority websites
some do's and don'ts on the content so
take into account the best practices i
mentioned
about creating high quality content
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear
you know because that likely is going to
be their search and so you want to be
able to respond to
the end user that's part of creating
high quality content
different types of content i.e in the
form of infographics or videos or text
or images you can add images from public
domain sites
you can be relatable and use examples to
clarify points just like the buzzfeed
article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language
talk to your audience as if you they
were standing right in front of you
and use bullet points to exemplify your
examples
your points so some do's the don'ts
obviously
don't lift content we don't want to
lift content from another website so
that's plagiarism
so we want to have our own unique
content we also don't want to take
images from other websites
and so if you do happen to find an image
that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website
ideally that's not a good situation but
if you do happen to do that then always
give
credit to the website okay so if you
took it from
xyz.com creditxyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take
images from other websites just as much
as you don't want to take copy you don't
want to take images
use your own imagery and content but if
you don't have imagery then you can
always
go to stock photography there are plenty
of websites out there where you can sign
up for a subscription
like adobe stock images as an example
you could sign up for an account and in
some cases
you can sign up for a free account and
use stock imagery okay don't give less
information to your audience give them
to your audience what they deserve
which is the information they're looking
for they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes
give them the best banana bread recipes
incorporate your own images
break it up with titles give them a good
quality piece of content that they're
going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs
in your content then it's going to be
less engaging so
try to avoid those long paragraphs
remember shorten up the paragraphs
keep the language simple add in images
answer those questions use third party
credible sources but write it in your
own words
and you should be on your way to
creating good quality content
okay so now that we've talked about high
quality content
in order to get your pages ranked high
on google search let's
turn our attention to optimizing on page
elements
and discuss some website level factors
that are both going to help you rank
high on google search
so let's just do an overview of what
we're talking about when we talk about
on-page elements and website level
factors
so optimizing on-page elements include a
number of different things but primarily
we're going to focus in on meta tags
also known as meta description tags
header tags also known as title tags
and urls so those are just some of the
on-page
elements we want to be able to optimize
using
relevant keywords in order to rank high
in google search
we also want to take a look at some
website
factors that will affect our ranking on
google search
they include website architecture having
a secure website
having a site map and taking a look at
page speed
so all of those are some of the website
factors we need to take into account
in order to rank high on google search
so
title tag and meta description together
are considered meta tags so both play an
important role
in ranking high on google so we want to
be able to write
unique title and descriptions for each
page on our website
when i say unique that means the title
and the meta description
need to be different for every page on
the website
and so if you're not quite sure what a
title tag and a meta description tag is
if you go to search and just type in
any particular search query the title
tag is what's going to show up here
and bold and then the description is
going to show up below it
below the url and that's going to
describe the page
so both of these meta tags are important
because it describes what your page is
all about
and that's what google uses in the
search results pages
so we want to be able to pay attention
to the length
of our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results pages met title tags are
generally
60 65 characters meta description tags
are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's going to happen
is the meta description tag
or the title tag will get truncated and
so if we look here for example
we can see all of the title tags here
fit
the 65 character limit but
if you run over the character count on
meta description
then google is going to truncate the
copy
so you want to stay within your
parameters in order to avoid
getting your content truncated and so
the other thing when we're writing title
meta description tags we want to
minimize keyword repetition so if we're
optimizing for keyword we don't want to
necessarily just
plug that keyword into the title tag and
meta description
multiple times we want to make sure our
title
tags and meta descriptions are naturally
written so if somebody's typing for
banana bread recipe
with dried figs you know we want to have
a nice
title tag and under this description
that is going to get somebody to
respond uh based on their need and so we
definitely want to avoid keyword
repetition but we want to be able to use
that keyword
in the title tag because if you remember
from the earlier segment
when we did the all in title syntax to
find out exactly
how many competitors were using that
particular keyword
well we obviously want to use that
keyword in the title tag because again
the title tag is an important
factor when it comes to search engine
results
so we want to use the keyword but we
want to avoid
stuffing or using it repetitively in our
title tag and our meta description
we want the title tag and the meta
description to describe the page
sound natural but also be engaging
because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines
so title tags with numbers tend to
result
in higher click-through rates this is
according to mods
so for example if you just put in a
title tag that says learn digital
marketing well
that may work but if you put a number in
there like five
easy ways to learn digital marketing
that might get somebody to click
on your link and go to your website so
having
questions in your meta tags can also
increase your click-through rate for
example
if you just put learn the importance of
first page rankings
not too bad but again generic but if you
put it
into the formal question how to rank
number one on google
it's more action oriented it's going to
get somebody to resonate with the
question that they have
and that may be their query how to rank
number one on google
and so these techniques will
help you get higher clickty rates and so
according to
backlinko title tag with a keyword can
improve site ranking
so remember we want to include that
keyword in the title tag even though we
only have 65
characters we want to include that
keyword but we want to avoid
stuffing the keyword in there we want to
again make the title tag
action oriented maybe with the number
maybe as a question
with the keyword in there once naturally
not easy to do
but that's the beauty of seo if you can
follow these best practices
and write a good title tag then the
chances of you
improving in your search results are
going to be greater
so having only one h1 tag in your post
is going to be good so remember when
somebody clicks
on a link so let's say they do find a
title tag engaging
and they click on this this link here
and they go to that website
you know you want to start out with
having that particular
h1 tech because the h1 tag especially
with the keyword in it
is going to signal to google hey we're
organizing our page
and because it's an h1 tag it's
important we're structuring the page
according to best practices
so having only one h1 tag in your post
is definitely
helpful having multiple tags h tags in
your post
help organize the page a lot better so
we want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag
and your header tag should be relevant
to the content so if we go back to our
example
of the using dried figs with banana
breads
well the title says california fig
banana bread and remember the last
segment when we're talking about high
quality content
we'll look no further than including a
video
into our content so not only will this
video help
keep the engagement high but it breaks
up the monotony of the page
and it's from a third party source so it
adds credibility to the page
so adding a videos based on the last
segment of high quality content
definitely helps with ranking high on
google search
so following hierarchical structure that
means putting those h tags in there
h2 tags help break up the content
and we want to avoid repetition of h1
tags on your different web pages of your
site
meaning don't just put the same h1 tag
with the same keyword in it
and keeping it blase we want to make
those h1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques
we want to avoid hidden tags we want to
avoid stuffing keywords
we want things to be natural we don't
want things to be
forced and your h1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters
don't make long h1 tags if we go back to
our page example
a short sweet tag here california fig
banana bread
it's relevant to the content it's short
sweet and breaks up
the monotony of the content and more
importantly and again
any content you have on the page should
always answer the user's intent
remember people are using search to
answer questions
find information our content should be
able to answer that for them
so according to john muller senior
webmaster trends analyst at google
header tags would definitely help google
for rankings in the search results
so we want to use header tags so when it
comes to urls
we want to use hyphens and avoid
underscores
so if we look at this url here this uses
hyphens
fig and banana bread so it's all broken
up with hyphens that's a best practice
remember canonical urls a canonical url
signals to google this is the original
content
so we want to use original content and
if you have multiple sources of content
out there on say different websites we
want to use a canonical tag
to signal to google this is the original
content
please index this content and that
doesn't hurt to use a favicon
url meaning a small icon it helps
to break up the monotony and help your
url stand out
we can add targeted keywords in the url
so again looking at the url here
i can see we're using targeted keyword
as part of the url structure
vegan banana bread and notice the h1 tag
is fake banana bread so it's all
consistent
and it flows naturally urls that are no
longer
existing then we want to be able to set
up a redirect for those urls meaning
a 301 redirect is a server response
for google that says hey google this
page is no
longer available but we permanently
redirected it to this page which is now
available
so that's what a 301 redirect does it
helps signal to google and all the other
search engines that if the page is no
longer there that's fine
you're just going to go to this page
this is the page that's permanently
there now
and another thing we want to do here is
if you have
mobile urls you want to include those in
the sitemap and we're going to hit on
that
in just a minute but all urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account those
best practices keep your url short
use hyphens put the keyword in that url
and make it easy to understand want to
avoid capital letters in the urls the
urls are
case sensitive so go lowercase you
should always go
lowercase from the url readable urls
again
the rule of thumb here is if you
understand what the url is
then google is going to understand what
the url is so the shorter the url
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read
the better chance you have to rank high
on google search
so according to backlink 2 urls that are
shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those urls
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable
so those are some on optimized ways or
on-page elements that help you optimize
now we want to look at some
website level factors that will help you
optimize and rank high on google search
so good site structure provides better
crawling for search engine bots and what
do we mean by that
well we mean having your site organized
in a fashion
that google's going to be able to find
all the pages so
what do we mean by that create a logical
hierarchy
structure so if you're selling shoes you
know you're going to have a home page
break the structure up into men's shoes
women's shoes
children's shoes then under men's shoes
you could have it by brand it could be
nike puma adidas on the women's side it
could be nike puma adidas
on the child side it could be nike puma
adidas and so you want to keep the
structure
flow in a hierarchy do we want to
balance the amount of subcategories
within each category
so the men's if it has nike puma adidas
the women should have
nike puma adidas and so you want to code
your site navigation and css or html
meaning we want to be able to use
something that google is going to be
able to index
so most sites are built in html and
that's what google likes to index they
like to index something that they could
take back to their servers
and then more importantly build a
comprehensive structure for internal
linking so internal links mean that
if you're on a site you should have
natural links pointing to
other pages on your website so to keep
the flow
going and we don't want to have
unnatural inbound things
you always want to have natural internal
links to keep the flow of the user going
from one page to the other so here i
could see
as an example all the ingredients in
this recipe well
this has an internal link to another
page on our site and this happens to
link to
a page where somebody can buy the
ingredients so it's a natural internal
link
so john doherty of credo has claimed
that one of the biggest
changes that he can make in fixing the
credo website
is architecture so for example in credo
john dougherty has increased the organic
sessions by
74 and pages by per session by 41
just by changing the site architecture
so you'd be surprised
by changing the site architecture what
that will do to engagement
and so let's turn our attention to
secure versus non-secure
so what we mean by that is securing your
site
we want to make it sure that compliant
with certain protocols and so if we go
back here we could see
that this particular site is compliant
it is secure
https means it has a secure
license meaning the site is secure so
google likes secure versus non-secure so
non-secure would be
http so we want https
as our protocol and what that means is
just enabling
ssl certificates and that means when you
enable an ssl certificate
that means your domain or your protocol
is going to be turned to https
so google prefers sites that are secure
versus non-secure so if you use hsts
as a protocol that adds an extra layer
of security
over the https and hsts prevents cookie
hijacking
so adding multiple layers of security
always helps
in my opinion if you have an http
website a non-secure website you should
look
into buying an ssl certificate
getting your sites flipped over to https
because what's going to happen is your
url structure is going to change
when your url structure changes google's
going to recognize that because they're
going to index your site
and when they index your site they're
going to see those secure urls
and that's going to work favorably in
your favor
and help you rank higher on google
search so websites
using secure or https
have a higher chance of ranking higher
so https is a ranking signal because
google
indexes those pages so let's also talk
about site maps
so sitemap is one of the most important
ways to improve your website ranking why
well because sitemaps are a way to
organize all your urls into one file so
we're basically going to prioritize
all our web pages in a sitemap so if you
go to any particular website
and you type in sitemap xml
you're likely going to see all the pages
on your website
so usually the site map is located in
the root directory
so if i type in sitemap.xml i'm going to
be able to see
all the pages in my root directory and i
can also
prioritize them i can also alert google
as to how
often they change and every page is
going to have
a date stamp associated with it so
google can actually see
how often it changes so remember we want
our content to be
updated frequently so content's not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then google's going to see that site
that date stamp that last modification
down so we want to be able to make sure
content is updated frequently we want to
let google know that we change it
frequently
and we want to be able to prioritize our
pages let google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be
set up in a sitemap we want to be able
to add canonical versions of urls in the
sitemaps so we want to be able to add
all our original urls in our sitemap and
so we always want to build dynamic urls
sitemaps for larger websites and what i
mean by dynamic urls that means that
if i look at this sitemap and we're
always adding content let's just say in
the form of a blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap
as they're published so as we add pages
to the blog or to the site then they
should automatically be added to the
sitemap
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see
the sitemap grow with more urls when the
sitemap grows with more urls
then that means then google is going to
index more pages
they're going to index more fresh pages
so they're going to be able to get those
pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
dynamic
site maps is we want to be able to
capture all the urls just as they're
published
and we want to be able to maintain our
site and so i would always recommend a
dynamic sitemap but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called xml
sitemap so if i just type in
xml sitemaps into google search
here i could see xml sitemaps generator
and i can be able if i have a small
website
just create a free and simple sitemap on
my own when xml sitemaps creates it
or your platform creates a dynamic
sitemap
either way the sitemap's going to sit in
the root directory
and then what we want to do in turn is
let google know
where that sitemap is so in search
console
we want to be able to submit the sitemap
so you're going to add the sitemap
you're going to let google know where it
is
it should be in the root directory and
it should be called
sitemap.xml and when you do that google
is going to be able to
take those urls and index them so we
could see we submitted 528 urls
google index 521 so one thing about urls
here
is when we create a sitemap we're
putting all your urls in there we
do not add no index urls in your sitemap
and what that means is that any url we
don't want
google to index we're just going to
exclude from the sitemap okay so we want
google to take
all the urls we want indexed and put
them in the sitemap so according to edgy
using sitemaps for seo can increase your
website's visibility and help you get
indexed
why because what you're in fact doing is
taking all your urls that you want
indexed you're telling google
how often they're modified you're
telling google which ones are important
and you're submitting that to google and
so google is going to be able to
take all those urls quicker index them
quicker and when they're indexed quicker
you can get ranked quicker and when you
get ranked quicker you can get traffic
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
site maps
so let's turn our attention to page
speed now so when the last
factors for our website besides
architecture
making it secure and adding site maps is
want to take a look at how
quick our pages load here are some tips
in order to optimize page speed because
ideally the quicker a page loads
the more engaged the user is going to be
if it takes a
longer time for the page to load all the
elements of that page
then what's going to happen is the user
is going to get impatient
maybe leave the website all together or
go to another page
and so we want to be able to optimize
images so
any image that's of large size in terms
of megabytes we want to be able to
optimize that to compress the image so
that's
one way to speed up page speed we want
to use a simple website design
you know html with css or cascading
style sheets
just a simple design with simple
hierarchy
and website navigation structure so
nothing fancy nothing complex
just a simple website design with
optimized images
we want to leverage browser caching and
we want to
upgrade the server response time meaning
all your files are sitting on the server
so
when somebody goes to web page the
server is serving
up all of those files the images the
text
etc and so we want the server to respond
as quick as possible so when it comes to
page speed we can
look at the factors affecting page speed
in google analytics so if i go to google
analytics
and i go under behavior and i go under
site speed and i go to overview
i'm going to be able to see what my
average load time is for my site
and ideally we want our pages to load as
quick as possible
so that means anything under four
seconds
anything four seconds or higher and it's
likely the end user is going to leave
the page
there's a correlation be between page
load time and bounce rate
and so what google actually does is give
you speed suggestions
so if we do have a page that loads slow
we can just go to speed suggestions
and google analytics and we go to speed
suggestions
then google's going to be able to tell
us hey this particular page load
fast this potential page loads slow and
if it loaded slow
why is it loading slow so here we could
see the home page of the example
is loaded on average of 7 seconds well
if we look here they're going to give us
some suggestions so if i click on this
page speed suggestions it's going to
load a report
and a tool called page speed insights
and basically
what it's then going to do after it's
done running is this going to tell
me all the ways in which i can optimize
my pages not only for desktop
but also for mobile so here i can see
for desktop
or for mobile i can look at some ways
in which i can optimize it to increase
page speed for example sizing my images
properly
server response time reducing my server
response time
avoiding multiple page redirect so
there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to
speed up page load time and all that's
found in page speed insights
and all that's found within google
analytics so remember optimizing code
minimizing redirects optimizing your
images
upgrading your server response and all
of those are factors
and so again you can go into analytics
page speed insights
and you can see exactly what google is
recognizing
as what's lowering or slowing down your
page load time
so google takes site speed as one of the
most
important ranking factors why because
they're going to rank pages
not only with high quality content that
are relevant to the keyword queries
but they want those pages to have a good
user experience so if somebody clicks on
the page then
the user should be able to see that
content fairly quickly and so that's why
it's such an important
factor so the quicker your pages load
the chances
of you ranking higher are going to be
better so according to web performance
today
walmart as an example experienced
declining conversions
so what they did was looked at their
page speed and
when they looked at their page speed
you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it
basically increase conversion so there's
always going to be a correlation between
how quick a page loads and how engaged
the user is
because if it's users engaged they're
going to stay on the site and if they
stay on the site
then their chances of converting are
going to be higher so just
even one to two seconds increase
in page load is low time will make a
world of difference
in terms of engagement and conversions
let's turn our attention to
off-site engagement so previously we
talked about
on-page elements and website factors
that
affect our rankings for search results
but we also need to turn our attention
away
from our website meaning what we do on
our website
and turn our attention what we can do
for our website off our website
and on to other websites so that's
off-site engagement
and so let's look at an example so that
ice cream recipes blog so we did
everything we possibly could we updated
the meta tags the title tag the meta
description we added h1 tags
we made sure the site architecture was
sound we submitted a site map
we we made sure the page load was good
and fast
so we did all the things we're supposed
to do on our web page
but we're still not ranking well what do
we need to do well we need to turn our
attention away from our website into
other websites we call this off site or
off page seo
and we need to basically generate links
from
high quality sites back to our site so
if we've done everything we can on our
own website and we're still
not ranking where we want to be well
then we need to turn our attention to
other websites
and so if we turn our attention other
websites
and other websites that are relevant
other websites that are of quality other
websites that have
high domain authority then we're going
to see
an increase in rankings so it's just a
matter of getting
quality links from quality websites that
are relevant
that's what's going to move the needle
on search
after we've taken care of all the
on-page elements
so more backlinks from high domain
authority results in higher rankings
seo is a combination between what we do
on our website
meaning optimizing the page and making
sure our website
has good site architecture and follows
the best practices in terms of site maps
and page load
then we need to turn our attention to
the backlinking to improve our domain
authority
so according to backlinko analysis
offsite engagement is one of the most
important elements for ranking number
one in google so
you can't just focus your attention on
updating the title tag and making sure
the pages load fast you have to turn
your attention
as well to getting back links from high
quality sites
that's off-site engagement and so
gaining links
back links from multiple danes is vital
it's vital because they bring
referring traffic to your site they
bring credibility to your site
but more importantly google's going to
recognize the relationship between these
sites and your website
and if these sites that have backlinks
or links pointing to your site
and if they're of high quality then we
call that passing link choose so it's
going to bring
quality to you in terms of organic
search
so if we look at an example if i do a
search for banana bread recipe
there are 241 billion results
for banana bread recipe why did this
particular page
from simply recipes rank number one well
we can turn our attention to moz and maz
has a report called link explorer
and so ma's link explorer report
helps us identify our own page authority
our own domain authority and how many
links we have from
other quality websites so if i put that
particular url
into link explorer and notice the url
here is short even though it uses an
underscore when it shows a hyphen it's
still ranked number one
and why because off page elements help
this page rank number one why their page
authority
out of 100 is 58 their domain authority
out of 100 is 82. and what does that
mean well
that means that they have a lot of good
links from other domains
of high quality they have 824 linking
domains
to this one domain they have 3 600
inbound links and they're ranking for a
lot of different keywords
so if we scroll down we're going to be
able to see
kind of a breakout the quality of
websites that are linking to them
so they have 19 domains with a domain
authority of 91 to 100
linking to them they have 15 domains
between the range of 81 and 90. so what
does that tell me between
15 and 19 that's 34
particular domains that are very high
quality
linking to it and so we could see the
breakout
of the linking domains we could see the
top file links to the site
and we could see the page authority so
the link explorer report gives us an
overview of what pages are linking to
ours
and it also gives us an idea of what our
own page authority and domain authority
are
because domain authority and page
authority both need to be high
in order for us to rank on google search
in order for it to get high
we need links from high quality sites
so that's the whole idea behind off-site
engagement
so some of the offside engagements are
influencer marketing meaning
is there somebody out there on social
who has a huge following
but not only do they have a huge
following but are they
relevant to our product for example
usain bolt
who's a famous sprinter if we're selling
shoes
and we're selling nike shoes maybe usain
bolt
can reference us on twitter or facebook
that's influencer marketing getting
people to
influencing people to buy our product we
can engage with audiences on multiple
social media platforms
like facebook and twitter meaning if
we're running a promotion on those
running shoes
then we can promote that on facebook
okay we can promote that on twitter
we can also bookmark our webpage on
popular bookmarking sites like
stumbleupon
we can also put our content on
discussion forums like reddit
we can join high pr quality
a q a sites excuse me and post answers
to questions related to our business
like cora.com
so we can engage in sharing our content
and answering questions
so there's lots of ways to get
links to your website if you have a blog
post as an example
you can make sure that maybe that
content is shared on a similar blog post
so if you have an
ice cream recipe blog post well
maybe you can look at a dessert blog
post and share
your content on that particular blog
post and
have a backlink pointing from that blog
post to yours as an example
and you can reciprocate so the whole
idea of content is sharing the content
but at the same time of sharing it
you're producing backlinks and backlinks
help
domain authority so not only do they
help domain authority
but they improve the search rankings so
in google's eyes the higher your domain
authority
higher the page authority in google's
eyes that means your page is important
it's credible
and we're going to improve it in the
search engine rankings
it increases brand visibility if we have
our content on a
highly engageable website a highly
popular website or a blog
it's not it's going to lift our brand
visibility if we have usain bolt
who's very famous sprinter do some
influence in marketing for us
then that's going to increase our brand
visibility so anytime we can associate
with something
that has some influence or some clout
or high domain authority then it's only
going to increase our brand
awareness and visibility so again it's
going to increase our domain authority
because of the association
of passing link juice from one domain to
another
it's going to then as a result increase
referral traffic
because if we're on a high quality
website that gets a lot of traffic then
the chances of some of that traffic go
on our site is going to be great
and again it improves the credibility
and trust of our website and that's what
we want we want google to trust
us and a way to build trust is by
associating
our website with other websites of high
equal or higher quality
so when we talk about offsite engagement
we want to
do some guest posts on relevant websites
so
if you have that ice cream blog go to
another blog
like the dessert blog and do a guest
post
so not only that will that improve your
brand awareness but
it'll generate a backlink and maybe
drive some referral traffic
you can participate in forums and blog
discussions
like core.com or reddit get your content
out there start a discussion about a
specific topic
to engage users build brand awareness
and generate that backlink
you can always you know put your your
site on a directory like
yelp for example or yahoo directory
you could prefer testimonial link
building meaning if you serve
products or offer up a service well
somebody could provide a testimony on
their website or you could just earn
backlinks from relevant authoritative
web pages
like we mentioned quora or wikipedia
there's plenty out there
so the idea is to associate yourself
with high quality websites but do it
naturally you don't want to force
anything
so if you're selling a specific service
or you're selling a specific product
look for like mining services or
products that complement what you do and
that'll create the natural environment
natural ecosystem
that will eventually give you the
benefits that you need
to rank higher in the search results
pages so we don't want to purchase any
links
we don't want to cloak content we don't
want to just inject
links on sites that aren't relevant we
don't want to just have
site-wide links all over the place
pointing to the same page
and we certainly don't want to be on
low-quality websites or directories
it's all about quality not quantity with
offsite engagement
so having offsite engagement complements
what you do on your website for onsite
together
both of those efforts will get you
higher search engine results
let's go over some key takeaways for
today's session we started out with the
keyword research
remember with the keyword research it's
all about relevancy
combined with volume and low competition
so that combination is going to get you
the key
words you need for on page optimization
so use good tools at your disposal like
google's keyword planner google's
keyword planner is going to give you the
volume you need
use the the all in title syntax on
google to get an idea of competition
cluster your keywords together in themes
like bread recipes
look for a bunch of keywords related to
bread recipes if that's
what you're trying to optimize for pick
the keywords that are going to generate
high quality content
so when you pick good keywords that
generate high quality content
then focus on the high quality content
you want to
start with a good title you want to
choose keywords that are going to
complement the content that you can work
into the content naturally
you can you know organize the content by
using headers
you can write your content so it's going
to be easy to understand write shorter
paragraphs
incorporate images call outs videos
you know mix it up a bit add ctas in
there make it engaging
answer the user's questions all of these
are going to contribute to good quality
content
whole idea beyond good quality content
is to make sure your users are engaged
because the more engaged in the content
the better chance you have to rank on
google so when you create content that
gives you the opportunity to optimize
that content
and by optimizing we mean working those
keywords naturally
into the meta tags the title tag in the
meta description
you know work those keywords into the
header you know make sure the header
is short sweet concise but powerful
and it makes sense it's relevant to the
content
you make sure the url is short but
readable and then we talked about
off page so off page elements for the
website
meaning submit the site map look in
google analytics at page load time
make sure your site's secure and once
you do all those things to your website
all those factors then you could turn
your entire attention
to link building off-site engagement we
talked about influencer marketing or
social platforms
or other websites that are going to
not only provide a link but they're
going to give you credibility
brand awareness they're going to refer
traffic to your website
and then they're going to overall
improve your domain and page authority
so all those factors combined are going
to help you
improve your search engine rankings
thank you rob
for that interesting session i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
give this video a thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to the simply learn
channel
for more such videos
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here